[Music]
it really did
[Laughter]
oh my god you don't know how much we
enjoyed that man welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm
mark bernard
hey
oh
we were uh we we too like all of you
were watching the counter
climb and rise and like come on we lost
20. how'd that happen
we lost a beaker i was that was more fun
than [ __ ] vegas and we win either way
we win but either way i just feel like
we needed steve kornacki to be up here
on the big board to tell us which
districts we lost four people from
we got our own guy in a tie man where's
bamf man he could have [ __ ] given us
the results and [ __ ]
there he is
uh banff man is uh we're doing a home
show as you can see
so uh jc taking time off of his work
schedule to bring
me and mark directly to you normally we
would be at the scum and villainy
cantina uh we're not tonight we're home
we're in the comfort of rome oh mark's
on the [ __ ] moon or something where
are you back i am on the uh i'm on the
bridge of the
executor i believe uh [ __ ]
you know the the official flagship of
the imperial navy you better not mouth
off to the boss he's one of these guys
he's one of those yeah do it daddy
children
twister man
in my version of star wars when he does
this he's twisting your nuts
god that's a different kind of joke
what's that what's that series that uh
you know fantasy star wars or what's it
called
visions
yeah give me a picture way more specific
give me that visions episode where
[ __ ] vader's just choke force choking
everyone's nuts
and they're like what the when did this
start and he's like he realized that
he don't get the same impact with
throats anymore man he's you've been
choking trots for years nobody gives a
[ __ ] anymore you go after their nuts you
got their [ __ ] attention i like how
every season the producers of star wars
visions go to you for an episode and the
first one is the audio erotic fixation
of the dude who just wants to be choked
hard hey season two what do you got
smitty well here's what we're doing now
he's four squeezing nuts like that it's
so weird because it's not even my kink
if my wife tried to choke me in bed i'd
be like what the [ __ ] what are you not
i've been waiting for my wife try to
choke me in my sleep in bed but
not during sex mark never during sex
season three listen mr smith what are
you going to do with force choking and
nuts this time
well just do it i'm going to choke to
death on somebody's nuts that wound up
in somebody else's throats by way of
wait for it
of course
[Laughter]
just two guys being slowly brought
together through space like why what's
happening please no please lord vader no
oh you're gonna do it he's forcing
people to tea bag lifting them up in the
air and forcing the tea bag
that's
that's when star wars has my attention
again
no star wars has made tension again now
with [ __ ] tavro and felony man
they're doing some good ass star wars as
we saw
from a certain trailer that we shall
talk about momentarily book a boba
what i know a guy who shot it
shut up
um but before we do anything on this
here episode of fat man beyond which
we're starting early this is the early
bird special why me and mark are senior
citizens so
we're going to do the show and we're
going to go hit golden corral
and get a discount [ __ ] meal because
men of our age of a certain age
are entitled to senior citizen discounts
tell them about the blue plate special i
want my salisbury steak and i want it
pre-chewed i'm gonna get as many mashed
potatoes as i could possibly choke down
and i'm gonna make it difficult for him
because i'm gonna be like are these
vegan is this vegan i'm gonna get like
is this vegan
um before we do anything
we gotta give it up we got two sponsors
tonight we do
two sponsors i hope that turns somebody
on ladies and gentlemen two sponsors the
first of which
um you know
and you love ladies and gentlemen give
it up
for the people that take your stink away
ooh
i don't know what to say
they take a stink way
it's native kids and guess what it's
holiday natives man they sent this body
wash sugar cookie bro
sugar cookie shut up don't be so
delicious sugar cookie by native my wife
is gonna be using this on her body and
i'm gonna be
it ain't gonna be santa eating the
cookies let me tell you that much and
then also seasonal holiday candy cane
uh deodorant man how awesome is that i'm
gonna bust this
[ __ ] open right
it's child proof
right here
let's give it a smell
smells like candy cane man nice i'm
gonna put this on my piss i'm always
talking about how it's vegan i'm tempted
to eat it but i think that's because i'm
on uh i'm on
45 hours of a fast so the idea of eating
this deodorant sounds appetizing
especially when it smells as good as it
does i feel like one of these days i
will have to catch you when you're not
in the middle of a fast
because it's rare at this like at this
point every time i see you're like yo
bro i'm like 89 hours into a fast
163 hours into not eating anything i
wish i could live my life on a fest
this this this smells [ __ ] amazing
dude i smell like christmas
if i put you in a headlock you would
think that santa was putting you into a
headlock because this candy cane [ __ ]
deodorant
is the tits i don't know if that's
confusing to the audience because if you
look in your armpits but my god i enjoy
this product man i'm feeling tingly i
feel tingly i feel alive mark oh nice
you feel fresh
being a headlock by kev post candy cane
deodorant it's like being tea bagged by
santa
uh here man ingredients
water what it actually means you know
this one water uh next ingredient is
like
camphor female beta team and what it
means
cleanse
derived from coconut oil they tell you
what all the ingredients mean you know
some most ingredients just list the
ingredients and you're like if i don't
have a physics degree how would i know
what this is they literally tell you
what each ingredient is nice i love
these these native people man what does
the copy say
the copy says
native cares about the products you put
on your body they're all about stopping
the stink the right way that's a native
difference with classics and rotating
seasonals native has a set for everyone
try their holiday scented deodorant body
wash or toothpaste and sends like a
candy cane yes mark sugar cookie yes and
fresh whiskey body wash smells [ __ ]
phenomenal
did you do it all no this is not why
people tune in but hey man we all got to
get clean this [ __ ] smells [ __ ] good
do you need a minute
i might want to drink it
might do it smells good i [ __ ] it's
making me hungry go ahead back to the
copy
uh so stay merry happy and fresh this
holiday season you will love natives
limited time seasonal products as much
as we do go to nativedeodorant.com
and use code fat man to get 20 off your
first purchase at checkout that's
nativedeodorant.com
code fat man for 20 off
nativedeodorant.com
code fat man
do it do it
doing it well it smells good
i'm gonna go for a second round man
lather up you know what i'm saying
i'm gonna put it between my tits as well
i like uh tuning in for [ __ ] bath with
kevin smith
where's bath
washing my junk in the sink this is
giuliani's shaving at a [ __ ]
restaurant but i guess yeah nobody tunes
in to watch me
i'll tell you native right now is now
that's how you sell the product
do it slowly this i'm this body wash
like is
i i don't know
it should be illegal to make something
smell this good but not be edible
yeah well tell that to medicine
i got a little on my nose but i don't
care because
you know what it's body wash
do it
wash that [ __ ] up
oh my
oh my god you're right
dude i'm gonna make my wife like lather
herself in this
she uses native anyway so i'm gonna be
like here man here my little sugar
cookie
and then
like a keebler elf i'm gonna eat her out
i i was wondering what road we were
going to go down
i didn't expect keebler elves and
cunnilingus but [ __ ] it
uh native that was a free commercial for
keebler like hey
thanks for the drive-by shout out native
folks
uh proud sponsors
of fat man beyond and i'm wearing it
well let's not
they might not be proud
but they're definitely
um we love the good folks native thank
you for sponsoring batman beyond uh i am
uh in a fa in the midst of a fast and
smelling as good as i can because i go
out on the road tomorrow mark
i start a tour
a mini tour of uh with the malcolm
ingrams documentary
clerk
which is the story
of a a man who wears many hats
all of them backwards
um it's uh the story of my life played
at south by southwest we just played at
the philly film festival so we're taking
it out on the road me and malcolm going
to a few places to show the flick
um i have a trailer and i
i
want to show it but i'm worried that
they'll knock our show off youtube if we
do but
if i if the trailer is about me
and i'm in this show
will the algorithm still kick me off
like will we still get in trouble as we
always have for those who are like
what's your problem historically we've
never been able to play a trailer on
this show without getting in trouble
from youtube either they pull the plug
on our broadcast or we get [ __ ]
angry emails or whatever to [ __ ] so
we're gonna try to play this clerk
trailer but mind you
they may
just pull the plug as they've been want
to do but i think that would be unfair
i'm deeply involved with this movie
this ain't us trying to show [ __ ]
morbius god forbid
i'm sure grace randolph gets to show
morbius but for some reason
fat man beyond like we don't get to show
trailers without getting knocked off so
fingers crossed
let's uh let's let's watch uh this clerk
trailer you got it jc spinner up man
we're coming up on the foundation upon
which my entire life was built
we would sit around at the quick stop
and we started noticing these ads for
these midnight movies
in the car ride home you could see this
intensity in his eyes this is what i've
been waiting for my whole life i want to
do this there was nobody in film school
or anything that could write like him
it's going to be on my tombstone he's
not even supposed to be here today i'm
not even supposed to be here today
everyone got us this to the news they
tapped into the subculture when i saw
clerks it felt like i belong to this
[Music]
i was immediately trying to set up the
next thing i got a phone call from the
head of the studio because we're going
to make 100 million
he was off by 98 million
we were in and now we're not kevin it's
had a lot of ups and downs in his career
and a lot of resurrections at a certain
point i gave up on kevin smith filmmaker
maybe it's because the critics were like
he's no filmmaker i'm like all right
they're right but i got to a point where
i'm like i think i'm going to be so much
more
the podcast the stage shows the hosting
making movies carved his own path he was
able to energize geek culture evan smith
is the man he changed everything
it's me doing everything that i've never
imagined i'd wind up doing i do actually
think like he got where he wanted to be
now i just want to be kevin smith i want
to be the kevin smithiest kevin smith i
could be from now until the end of time
because that's all they'll remember
about me when i'm gone
[Music]
oh look at that
we're back you're watching on youtube
i was i was just playing the [ __ ]
trailer and reading the remarks i got
this uh one of these comments maybe this
makes sense
uh gnome
cyan said you guys probably get in
trouble because you have the trailer
filling the whole screen
we've done it before though we've done
we've done the boxing box before and
still got yanked we got [ __ ] for that
too bamf yeah it's picking up the
like the audio of it it's not picking up
the video i think it's the audio that's
doing it
um but it also does it on the video
because like i believe we've actually
muted the trailer and played it and you
guys have talked over it and we still
got hit for that too
yeah i just don't like us
we uh we're i'm heading out tomorrow i
go to austin
so tomorrow night i'm sean clerk at the
paramount theater in austin then we do q
a afterwards me and malcolm
then i go to
rhode island comic con
on friday not with clerk just with the
clerks
cast there's a bunch of people from
clerks and clerks too going to be there
and stuff me
jay
brian jeff marilyn
scott shafo like
i think trevor's going as well like the
list goes on
so i'm going there and doing the photo
thing and we got a panel at night and
stuff
then saturday i go to jersey and we have
two
sold out shows at smod castle of clerk
sunday i go to st louis
and we show the movie at the pageant
theater
then we go to chicago the next night on
monday
and we show it at the music box theater
then i go to toronto and we show it at
the queen elizabeth theater
then we have a day down and then i go
over to vancouver and we show it at the
rio theater
so if you're in austin
uh well new jersey's sold out if you're
in austin st louis chicago toronto
or vancouver and you feel like risking
your life to see a documentary about
kevin smith and then
do q a with him afterwards and whatnot
and the director of the movie malcolm
ingram come join us tickets are at
seasmod.com kids
um and somebody asked hey what about if
i can't get to any of those places the
movie comes out streaming everywhere i
believe at the toward the end of the
month or something we're just doing this
little tour for
places that you know have historically
always been very welcoming to us and
whatnot wanted malcolm made a move a
film and you know he didn't he got to go
to south by southwest but
it was online
he didn't really get the film festival
experience and whatnot so i was like
let's take it out on on tour and it's a
[ __ ] feel-good movie if ever there
was one man like oh my god but he made
such a good flick and i know the story
real well but even i get lost in it
where i'm like i hope it works out for
this [ __ ] poor kid
that tells you how [ __ ] watchable it
is um so i do all that when that's done
i come back here
to los angeles
um for a few days i got some stuff to do
then i'm going to
to pick up my mom in florida and we're
going to drive to graceland i'm going to
take grace to graceland oh that's so
sweet yeah she's expressed an interest
red red told me she my friend our friend
red she was just like your mom has
always wanted to go to graceland and i'm
like
she's my mother i don't know this how is
this [ __ ] why do you know this yeah i
was like what the so i was like mom have
you never been to graceland do you
really want to go graceland and she was
like i would love to go to great science
so
taking grace to graceland
nice that's my middle of the month
that's november for me oh you were going
to eat so well on that trip you can get
some ribs in st louis some some good old
soul food and in memphis you can get
some [ __ ] poutine in vancouver some
[ __ ] deep dish chicago pizza in
chicago oh you're not you're just being
cruel aren't you to a plant-based man
mark well they have vegan versions of
all of that stuff right i don't think so
yeah probably not had a vegan version of
ribs that'd be fun um but yeah they'll
have they'll have food for my kind where
i'm going
have some hummus
um it's always you know weird when you
go to like big meat places like texas
whenever you go to texas
you're like hey man where's the vegan
joint they're like
y'all eat grains like
yeah but you should be able to get some
good [ __ ] like tex-mex and good beans
yeah that's what i'm looking forward to
man real
[ __ ] uh refried beans not uh not well
i guess you know actually here in los
angeles you get real refried beans
yeah yeah you know but yes there's
something to eat down there i'm gonna
make it happen no that sounds like a
great trip and i'm uh i look forward to
the grayson graceland uh report it's
gonna be it's gonna be fun man she seems
like so thrilled about the notion i was
like oh my god like you know we'll be
hours in the car and she loves to
think about how much i love to talk this
is my mother the apple did not fall far
from the tree
so
it'll be a battle of who's talking more
for the whole [ __ ] ride and stuff top
of december
um i'm going to be going back east we're
going to do a
jingle j and santa bob uh you know thing
at jay and salam bob's secret stash
um
but uh then we also
shoot december 7 we're doing pickups i
saw it online somebody was like reshoots
for clerks three it's not reshoots it's
pickups we're grabbing people that we
haven't shot for the cameo scene in that
movie
um and at that point once we grab that
then picture will be
[ __ ] locked at that point we had a
great screening at lionsgate
last week and it was uh for the
marketing folks and and uh folks that
are um gonna do marketing beyond the
movie itself like merchandising
marketing as well
and i saw some places where i was like i
could trim nuggets from there so i
pulled out another like 30 seconds and
we've been playing musical chairs pun
intended with the music as well as we
find out what things cost so there's
some songs that i'm like we need this
song no matter what i don't care what
the cost
like welcome to the black parade by uh
you know my chemical romance opens the
movie and you know i was like whatever
to cost we're getting that song so there
are some tracks that are definitely like
you know i'm dug in like a tick on but a
lot of it is now mutable and based on
price
so you know if there was a song that was
on the original clerk soundtrack that we
were going to have on this soundtrack a
piece
to play over a scene because it played
over the scene in the original
but the cost was too high they wanted
like 40 grand for it and i'm like i'm
using it for 10 seconds like i can't
i can't do it so you know we'll find
another track to put in there instead so
right now that's what we're doing is
playing
kind of musical chairs with music going
this piece here this piece here i was
very lucky we got a kid who works with
us back east christian who did like the
making of the smod castle videos when
ernie was building smart castle when he
was building jane salab's secret stash
rebuilding it
um christian's dad i've talked about him
before i met him years ago at the ocean
county mall his dad was the lead singer
of pm dawn
so he had a track
that he was like it's been
nobody ever heard has been unreleased
and stuff that is like
a thing of beauty and pitch perfect in
the movie and stuff so i've i've added
that there was a place in the movie
where i was using
uh time as type by booker t
um you know for a montage sequence but
the song as beautiful as it is i mean
you know the piece of music is very
expensive
so i was like well if i'm gonna pay for
a piece of music let me pay for a song
nobody's
heard before buy a new jersey band pm
dawn was also a new jersey band
so um i shifted that in uh today
and poignantly i had to write text
christian because um where the song
falls in the movie
uh christian while we were shooting the
movie has a cameo he's one of the people
buying something in the store walking
out at the beginning of the scene but
right now his dad's
who passed away a few years ago
his dad's voice his dad sings over his
shot no that's nice really really
[ __ ] nice man so it's cool cool to
get a great piece of music nobody's ever
heard before from a band that i've loved
my whole life
but also cool when you can make
little magical [ __ ] like that happen as
well ain't gonna matter to the whole
world but it's gonna matter to people
that matter you know at least matter to
christian and his family so
uh yeah that's what i'm kind of working
on the movie somebody was like what's
going on with the movie
um it
feels like you know
mid-2022 is
gonna be the landing spot no no date yet
but that's what they're they're looking
at and discussing there's one song that
i hope stays because i smiled ear to ear
when i heard it i won't say what it is
in case it falls out but i remember
watching it going like oh
i like that song well chosen sir
tell me
i don't tell me let me see
um
the show
is it gone no
no
not only is it not gone and thank you
for [ __ ] like
uh my whole life i've been waiting to
put the show in a movie
finally i had a scene where i'm like oh
my god oh oh oh my god as we check
six minutes doug refresh your eye oh
still to this day like if [ __ ] uh you
say six around jason muse it'll be like
six minutes dougie fresh you're on
so that that track is deeply meaningful
to me and being able to use it in the
movie was absolutely the you know for me
i put in the temp cut and i'm like well
let's see if it works and [ __ ] did it
work so i was like look i'm married to
this in a big bad way thankfully
christian's family is very tight
with dougie fresh so
nice so
that seems pretty damn secure in in the
movie um i mean the last time i smiled
that wide at a kevin smith uh needle
drop
was uh follow the leader and cop out and
i was like oh
this is great
you're just you're telling me like i
literally forgot that we had an eric b
and rock kim track and cop cop so much
of cop out i
had to block
there's also a car chase and i'm like
this is a perfect song for a [ __ ] car
chase
no [ __ ] rock him say but then
i wanted to use
um
i ain't no joke but
the
track itself was not expensive the
sample the james brown sample
was
far more expensive than the track itself
um so yeah we're you know we've got a
healthy budget for music in the movie
but
you know that's when when we were
budgeting the flick that's not
the priority and so you know we got a
figure in there that's good but like not
where you could go crazy so we're in
that very
selective period where i'm like all
right how much do i love this song or
how
meaningful is this song to the movie how
well does it fit do others dig it like
i'm so glad to hear somebody go like i
love the show like oh
i'm glad the inspector gadget um
underlying music writer was not like
[ __ ] i want all my money
interestingly enough like i don't know
if that belongs to
to like because we've encountered
situations where like
well that has a sample so it prices you
out
so far that hasn't been
the case with this
but now you just scared the [ __ ] out of
me
where i'm like somewhere inspector
gadget is just like
oh no
oh no the dic people are like what's he
doing now yeah
and they start acting like real dekes
yeah and [ __ ]
noise
these are old school geek jokes
old school geeky dad jokes that's what
you came for if ever there was a time
for it now is it
um so yeah yeah that's that's where i am
with uh that's what that's what's going
on in my world what's going on yours um
not too much different since the last
time we hung out it's still
you know pre-production on the movie um
on the short i i hear i got a mark i
have a mark update that i can share and
i'll be very
um
um obscure with the details okay tell me
but um i had a thing that i was like oh
get mark like we'll get mark to help us
write this thing
and then i got the word back to like
mark too busy for you
mark's committed to a thing and i and
him i was like oh my god i knew like i
knew that but at the same time i was
like oh he'll be able to
come and play but his mark is so busy he
precludes him from coming to do a thing
with me that is [ __ ] success
you know i
only because we had talked about it
before when i was like yeah you know i
don't think i can
like i would love to but i don't think
they'll let me
um
but yeah it was just
like i i i would then be short shifting
somebody
one day we'll be able to tell people
like he didn't do this because he was
doing this and people will be like
wow
i get it
but but yes so i know i know how busy
you are even though you're like i don't
have much report i know you're working
on a thing that takes up a lot of a
thing
it does um i had a thing um implode
which i suppose i can talk about in
again general terms non-specific terms
but it was it was the the steadiest
thing during the pandemic was the the
very last in-person meeting that i had
was with a studio asking if i wanted to
adapt a book they had the rights of this
fantasy book that i had never read
before um but i was like i don't give a
look sure why not i like the studio i
like the people so i'll take a look and
i read the book and i i i found my way
in right the project every time there's
an open writing assignment or every time
there's ip that somebody has the only
way that you can spend the amount of
time you're gonna need to spend on it is
to find your way into it find out what
you know can you respond to how you can
make it special
how it can be the story that you're
trying to tell and so i did i found my
way in
i pitched it to them they loved it i
then pitched it to the network who was
attached and they loved it and so they
sent me off to write to start the
process of
writing a pitch document writing a bible
writing an outline all of which there's
notes along the way and this is like
months are starting to tick by and
finally got the green light to write a
pilot so wrote the pilot script and you
know and then three four five drafts of
the pilot script and then everybody's
happy with it and then it goes to the
decision-making people who decide okay
we are going to spend 100 million
dollars and make this tv show or we
won't
and
you know after about a year like again
it was it was january of 20
2020 i guess would have been like just
before we stopped meeting people for
real
all the way up until like
a month ago
it had been an ongoing concern and and
and then a month ago i got the words
again we're not going to go forward with
it
which
you know is heartbreaking to a certain
degree because you've invested
all kinds of time and effort and
there's thousands of words that have
been written in support of this thing in
100 different drafts of stuff
but you know the reality of hollywood is
most things don't happen most things
don't go
um
you know and and it's always sad and you
always have to mourn for a little bit of
the the show that was or could have been
and the time you spent and the
the emotion you invested in it
but that's that's the cost of doing
business and so
it just it went tits up to to you know
not
hopefully use two course of phrase
but and so yeah moving on like it's one
less iron that's in the fire and
there's no chance for it to to appear
anyplace else the people who own it the
people who would air it have the rights
to it so they're not shopping anyplace
else so it's just you put in the ground
and you say your goodbyes and
on to the next one
we've all been there man
we've all been there i was um
i did that disney thing
plus before disney plus existed they
were like
first show is going to be high school
musical
the musical or whatever it was the show
it's like 12 years ago the musical the
show or whatever the like second program
is going to be kingdom keepers but that
was before
you know they they were like
wait a second
we're going to do mandalorian we're
going to do marvel shows like
in the beginning when they were still
birthing the idea of disney plus before
it even had a name and stuff
the disney channel
was in charge of all the programming and
stuff then you know they put this other
dude i forget his name but he he was the
guy that was like let's do marvel shows
let's do this and he was the dude that
killed our show
um and the word i heard back was that
dude was like
this
this property has way too many [ __ ]
made way too much i.p in it he's like
he's got every [ __ ] disney character
you know alive because that's what we
were developing like the book kind of
you know is about kids that go into
disney and and after dark and the park
comes to life
and [ __ ] like that real fun fantasy
stuff favreau tried to do a version of
it as a feature film like years ago
so
um you know it was
it i met with producers i've told this
story before like they took me to
[ __ ] disney after dark like and
we talked about the logistics of how we
would shoot the park sequences during
the day they were like we closed down
half the tunnel one tunnel for the
public the other tunnel
for you know saving mr banks when we
made that moving stuff so we could
totally do it they took us to space
mountain and we walked the track after
like turning all the lights on and [ __ ]
it was
crazy and the whole time i was working
on this thing i was like this is
i can't believe i got this job it's
never sooner or later it's going to stop
no way this happens no way this is going
to come they brought me to disney to the
lot and showed me the volume the
mandalorian wall that you know that like
they were like this is brand new
technology even before like [ __ ]
mandalorian happened and [ __ ] so they
were like this is what your your
backgrounds are going to be on no more
green screen we're using this and [ __ ]
and i remember i took video with my own
camera because they were like you can go
from any angle and it changes
perspective like it was wild
and
at that point when they when i met
producers when they showed me the volume
and talked to logistics
that's when i was like this show might
actually [ __ ] happen
but then
killed just instantly the dude who was
hired was like pull the [ __ ] plug and
i don't bear any [ __ ] ill will i was
like is all their property i didn't come
to them like this is my baby like they
came to me kind of well they said come
pitch and they like my pitch and i got
the job but like it was based on
you know a series of books that they
tangentially are involved with and stuff
because a fan they were fan written
books became very popular and then it
was based on all their walt disney ips
so like your situation it's not like
well i'm just going to take my [ __ ]
thing across the street and sell it to
warner brothers like you can't they own
this [ __ ]
so at the end of the day i was like you
know oh well
it's over now like that's where it's
dead in the water you know when it's
something you create
you can you know if somebody says no you
could always bring it someplace else and
by
dagnabbit you could pull yourself up by
your bootstraps and do it yourself indie
film style like
like that kid made that black and white
movie set in that little bodega years
ago
but in this situation you can't and all
that work belongs to them and they
they're like it's gonna go on a shelf
and nobody will
ever see it or deal with it and there is
a moment of like
well well that was that a waste of time
like did i just waste all my time but
number one
i'm sure like me you got paid to do the
job
so think about all the people who you
know i got a dream to do something the
dream don't come true they don't even
have a [ __ ] paycheck to show for it
yeah so we're like oh man i got a dream
that they'll do and it's not even a
dream we've had our whole lives it's a
dream since the opportunity happened
it's like i dreamed that this thing goes
and i got a steady job and i'm gonna
make some money and maybe get a good
story in or two be a little
self-expressive a bit security or
something like that
but you know still we got paid at the
end of the day and so when it goes south
you know there's this whole like be a
grown-up about it stiff up her lip like
that happens i'm a pro i understand
but you can't help but be intimately
involved with this material like i
enjoyed the people i worked with my
executives
made the story better and [ __ ] like
all the people i met over there like
changed my opinion about
studio execs for years like i was like i
worked with them on the early part of my
career and i'm like
they're not bright you know they're
[ __ ] answering notes that they got
and [ __ ]
this generation i worked with they were
all writers they made the work better
and [ __ ] and so there was a period of
[ __ ] morning where it's like oh and
even though
you know i spin enough plates like
yourself where i happen to know
the thing that didn't go away is [ __ ]
way better so it's like
i know you're safe as a kitten and [ __ ]
like that
but still
there's that moment of like oh
you know like it ain't happening and i i
put a lot of effort and dream into it
and stuff like that but again at least
we walk away with a check it's a weird
weird position because again
it's not like i earned this with my
blood sweat and tears like
you know
you came up with a fun way to tell a
story that they were like we like that
and they took it as far as they could
and then they were like eh it's not
worth the money or whatever the [ __ ]
we're not gonna do it
and it's weird it's like being
you know like it's it's almost like a
bunch of popular kids in high school is
like you
come [ __ ] hang out with us and you're
like [ __ ] hey this is how the other
half lives
and then all of a sudden they're like
you cut a fart and they're like get out
of here like you're you're out as
quickly as you were in
you're out and all the magic and the
light goes and they all everyone who
worked on it flees like the apostles
when jesus got arrested and [ __ ] and
they're all denying it like what kevin
smith never heard of him no i don't know
about that project
but it's so it's weird you go through
this weird period with it but at least
you got paid like you know that's the
only thing i always tell myself like
that's what my father would say you know
my father was like i worked at the post
office at night canceling [ __ ] stamps
for 25 years man you you like
you're gonna cry about they didn't make
your thing but [ __ ] you got paid like
that's your [ __ ] blessings and [ __ ]
but it is a weird
yeah there's this weird little death
that one as a creative as a writer
you have to kind of acknowledge like the
death of this little dream even though
all these other dreams are working out
it's like oh at one point in my in my
life at one point in your life
that job was the [ __ ] job
like that's the one everything and you
were like oh life's going to change and
[ __ ] and now you're on to other things
bigger better things
and this one goes away and you're like
oh that's a [ __ ] yeah it's the drag from
like the into the inactive files folder
which is somewhat ceremonial i'm just
like
[Music]
i don't have inactive files but the top
of my screen is are the folders where
everything's going on at the bottom of
the screen of the you know the land that
time forgot
before there's a forgotten dream the
island misfit toys you know the [ __ ]
didn't really quite pop didn't go
anywhere but i got plans for it too i
never throw [ __ ] out
like i got plans oh i got fancy plans i
got pants to match you'll see i can't
wait to talk about what we got brewing
man it's very exciting particularly
for this
audience that we talk to on a weekly
basis but more about that
yeah months from now and the other thing
that that did happen this week and again
it's not like this week this happened
but the announcement went out
is that uh similarly for the
most of the pandemic i have been working
with
um a woman named amy henning who created
and wrote um she was a lead writer on
the uncharted games
on a bunch of other like you know
notoriously phenomenal video games
started a division of skydance
interactive that's making games for them
and they announced this week that the
game we have been working on has been in
partnership with marvel
um
so
and i can literally like that's all i
can say about that but
i have spent the better part of a year
in the story minds coming up with a a a
marvel related video game
i i'm trying to be careful cause i i
know things
i i know you know things i'm trying i'm
just how do i say things without saying
things
what uh
what is what is what has been the
you said video game right yes all right
what has been the most
revelatory part of the writing a video
game process you haven't done it before
have you
not in this capacity um and not from the
beginning
but it's been realizing that
yes i have the story that i like we as a
team have come up with a story that we
like but you don't have all of the
language of cinema at your disposal
because
it's relentlessly
pov based
in that you can't really cut away to
other
story lines with information the player
would need to play the game
you know especially with story
information like
the the the player
has to always be the one who's getting
the information so that they can then
follow that thread so the whole idea of
like just cutting away to another
character doing a thing that's not
motivated by story or motivated to a
character you will then be playing
becomes
you start to minimize that stuff because
then it's just you're watching as a
thing as opposed to playing the game
one lesson one less uh arrow in the
quiver so to speak that you get to pull
out and fire right like those those
ideas of
surprise of reveals of that sort of
thing
the the player needs to be able to
follow along so the player doesn't feel
like they're behind the story so much
where they're not actively invested in
it so it's just a matter of kind of
recalibrating that stuff out of the
out of the language and then realizing
that yeah your players will need to play
a game and not just watch a thing so as
you're telling the story what's the
player doing in this
you know it's why lots of games have
like puzzles i need to solve when you're
also getting exposition at the same time
um and then watching people do things
it's a lot like animation in that
there's a whole design department that's
at work
you know feeding back images and designs
and locations and characters and costume
mockups and everything that's just
informing the storytelling as it goes
and it's
it's it's bigger at this stage than
anything else i've ever worked on
um so
first off
congratulations second off everyone in
chat seems to know
the name of the lady you mentioned
yes
amy henning yes
well like there was a lot of whoa there
was a and and then also
there's a lot of guesswork as to what
the game might be
and it's all over
the map did you i don't want to repeat
what did you describe it as
it is a it is a game
that is set using characters from marvel
comics
copy you so all of the guesses are
within the marvel universe so by process
of elimination you might imagine
somebody would trip over it
i saw one of the response nail it dead
where i was like wow oh yeah let me let
me look
uh look later don't look now
why not why why do i have to be the one
who doesn't look at chat
you're not allowed to look at chat mark
you'll see how much they love you and be
like i don't need kevin and it'll be
mark man beyond
uh we already got a [ __ ] offshoot
show bla
yeah where's mile this is the problem
you don't know the pain of being a
[ __ ] white man mark we don't get
we're forgotten we're we've never been
you know in first position or anything
like that oh so many woes
you wouldn't understand i you know i i
couldn't possibly
um
all right enough about us because you
know sometimes it just sounds like we're
being braggy and secretive that's even
worse because it's like we're not
telling people the things we're working
on we're like
but
we don't want to lose these jobs no no
no i'll go away real quick yeah um
however
i mean
all right so you said marvel right i did
say marvel
can we sidebar and just
and be like
so if you're in the world
do you have access to all information
that we don't
um
thus far
less information than you do
what i have no information
there's very much just like
you're stumbling around in the dark and
somebody will tell you if you're about
to walk on the third rail
so i would see in my head
you know once they're like come in it's
like ah choir of angels and you're
brought to a large desk and they're like
here's the next 10 years
like you know leaf through one page
per per project and it just lays out
phases [ __ ] you know up to phase 20
and whatnot but it sounds like no you're
you're not showing the
book i i
the game is also
one step removed from the mcu proper
right you know so i i don't even know
what it would be like to be working in
the mcu and how much information you
however don't have but i know that the
game side of it is
they will just tell you what you can't
do as opposed to show you everything and
say find your way that sounds like
from time to time
the the movie side too i've heard it
described thusly
um it would not surprise me they give
folks a road map it sounds like but they
also like him be creative
and then step out the way and whatnot
but they also
only share the information about other
projects
that
will
intersect or venn diagram with theirs
like is that from what i understand just
because you're working on
uh say hawkeye and this is just a random
[ __ ] pic because i saw somebody wrote
hawkeye in chat
uh just because you're working on
hawkeye
doesn't mean you know
anything about fantastic four
right even though we're all they're all
on the same [ __ ] you know uh paycheck
and they all work for the same company
they're still
incredible intricate levels of secrecy
yeah i mean i think we we got that
intimated as much from when we talked to
like malcolm spellman or we talked to
matt chapman talking about their
experiences was
you can learn things about the things
you need to know
but that doesn't mean you get to know
everything
i'm going for another hit man do it i've
never done this three layers in one day
but there's no unnatural [ __ ] in it so
i'm not worried about like you know
having a stroke or something like that
it's vegan
it's good for you it's vegan oh my god
it smells like christmas and you know
what mark we need a little christmas
right this very minute do we because it
was like just halloween i don't know but
it's a straw
man has joined us what's up man so we
did halloween all weekend at scum and
villainy
and i went a little bit on sunday night
i probably left around 11 o'clock
and i guess at midnight
one of our bartenders right at the
stroke of midnight as
uh october 31st became november 1st he
played mariah carey's all i want for
christmas is you
and just trolled the whole
bar like halloween's over christmas time
which i thought was the funniest like
bar gag like because we had you know 100
plus people in there
that had been drinking all night and all
of a sudden
it's mariah carey time hey man tell uh
tell us what the bar business is is like
now
uh it's it's show
we don't tend to talk about the crowd
but like there's a crowd there to see
the show but what what's it like when
there's no show going on people are
showing up to the bar
yeah it's super busy it's awesome um and
we are vaccine only
uh
so we get a little bit of trash talk on
the internet and a little bit of
problems at the door but once you're
inside everybody's gotten a shot or two
or three
so it's uh
it feels almost like we're
getting back to
way back 2019 when we were all naive
about how easy it was to spread sickness
i got my booster i got my booster
yeah i got my booster as well i got it
uh a minute ago
it didn't make me sick the first two
made me sick i didn't get sick my arm
didn't even hurt on the last one i'm a
pfizer i'm a pfizer man i got pfizer and
it i never got sick the only side effect
was like ow
like the next day it literally felt like
somebody punched me so [ __ ] hard in
the arm
but that was it my wife got moderna and
both times
when she got the original shots and when
she got the booster she was knocked out
for one day
yeah i'm i'm also house moderner
first of my name
oh god thank you for keeping it on bran
i was
like this sounds like an old man show
but that fun reference
saved the night
and uh and i just felt like sluggish for
a day like some brain fog and then it
kind of passed pretty quickly
none here man
none here i think because i'm like so
stoned all the time they're like the
side effects are like we can't make it
through is weed induced haze
that's because kids
i smoke jay and sam i mean we don't
smoke right no i mean
i've heard of this weed
i don't want to get thrown off of
youtube
you'd be thrown off i think youtube's
okay i think it's meta
that would throw you off mark
zuckerberg's new thing
meta i tell you so every week you know i
always put up a tweet
uh hey man [ __ ] uh we're about to
start the show join me on my facebook
page or my youtube channel
and i wrote you know
facebook
and it wouldn't let me put facebook it
only let me put meta so they've changed
their [ __ ]
twitter handle man
like there's a facebook app a twitter
handle but facebook
doesn't exist do they honestly [ __ ]
think that
people are gonna be like oh i like this
meta company facebook i was unsure of
because i hear they were
lending to the fall of our democracy but
like this meta company i'm all about
like
mama name and claim
this is the weirdest rebranding since
weight watchers just went with ww
and i say that as a former weight
watchers spokesperson
um it's a very it's it's strange but
yeah it's you can't type facebook
anymore there's no facebook twitter
address it's just meta it's all meta
that's so weird
we're being watched on meta right now
i mean nice try
i suppose but like i still know that kfc
stands for kentucky fried chicken
even if potentially legally they can't
say that it's chicken
so it's not just kfc that's not why they
changed their name they changed it
because fried was such a bad word in the
culture for a long time it wasn't
chicken they got real chicken there
unless you know something i don't
i mean that was the rumor but you know
it probably sit next to some rumors
about like richard gere
that are like woefully unproven but just
urban legend i i'll vouch for kentucky
fried chicken even though i'm
plant-based and i'm a vegan now
um
brag bragg um they uh they uh it's not a
brag believe me i get crucified for it
anytime i mention it that's why i try to
say plant-based because if i say vegan
be people like [ __ ] you
now don't touch this much meat and [ __ ]
because you said vegan
but uh but yeah they know they changed
their name because of the fried that was
the dirty word
because you know people were going
health conscious and writing their
[ __ ] name dude they're like fried
and you know we all know the fry well
take it from
cardiovascular disease kev ladies and
gentlemen uh fried food you know is no
damn good for your heart so
i think that's why they changed i don't
think it was because there was a scandal
about the chicken that's more like taco
bell like how much meat is in the meat
kind of thing yeah i don't know i just
i feel like if french fries can stay
being called french fries even though
they're fried
you could probably get away with just
saying kentucky fried chicken
um
oh look at this this never happens oh
god screw this in chat said that's a
popular urban legend mark kevin is oddly
enough
completely right why is it oddly enough
[Laughter]
i know things
i sounded like fredo right there i know
things i'm smiling i'm smart
um i do like that there's now this war
in chat who's like incorrect kevin it's
because they couldn't call a chicken oh
well kevin is oddly writing this it's a
promotion thing not a food thing for kfc
yes i just saw that one too motion thing
not a food thing for kfc
um mike clifford is reminding us that
we've got
we've gone way off tangent so we should
probably
you know nobody this isn't like [ __ ]
colonel sanders beyond it's fat man
beyond we're here to
talk about the culture that pops
ladies and gentlemen and how we do that
around these ear parts
is by diving into the news and the only
person who knows the news our very own
personal owatu
that watcher cuck who goes through the
news looking for things to talk about
mark bernard has brought you the news
here now with the news
is mark bernard
um
first point of fact i'm pretty sure if
we just call this the tangent show it
would do just as well in the traffic no
doubt um and also that's what a home
show was for my friends that traffic by
the way up to uh 2 400 people watching
look at that
um but yes let's talk about some things
namely uh in two days two trailers
dropped
oh which ones
um the first one that dropped was the
star wars book of boba fett
trailer
yes
yeah that that they stealth that one
stealth snuck that trailer you know it
wasn't like uh the morbius trailer
yesterday they were like hey man
tomorrow
morbius the latest marvel hero boy they
said marvel once they said a thousand
[ __ ] times
but the boba fett didn't seem like there
was any buildup maybe i missed it all of
a sudden i was
thumbing through [ __ ] twitter and or
i didn't want to say finger and that
sounded dirty uh but i never wouldn't
want to do that now i'm not a funny guy
i'm a i'm a pointer finger guy so i was
doing this on my phone man i was like
and i saw
the tr there's somebody talking about
book of boba and i was like what
dave klein shot it that's my boy [ __ ]
yeah on display i saw him take credit
for it finally on instagram today i
guess you know those cats are under
strict lock and [ __ ] key
um so he couldn't even say anything and
stuff but it's nice that he's able to
tell the world man that guy
the guy who shot clerks
clark's when he was a boy he was 19.
is she shooting the booga bow but he's
also shooting [ __ ] mandalorian season
three
talk about a glow up man that's not bad
he deserves it he work so [ __ ] hard
so hard i mean he had
clerks worked you know for me because
people like hey welcome uh clever new
young voice and [ __ ] ain't nobody ever
looked at clerks and said we gotta get
the guy that shot clerks like you know
it's not known for its look so dave had
to [ __ ] prove his medal and he did in
the trenches of true blood he shot that
for a while he shot homeland for a while
he shot dead wood like he's been all
over the map and stuff and now he's
firmly ensconced over there at
[ __ ] lucasfilm and they love his ass
look at that he went from boba he works
side by side with
like
with felony and [ __ ] favreau man how
awesome is that and rodriguez and
rodriguez that's right mm-hmm
um i
i'm gonna leave it right there
i thought it looked dope
i i think it's fantastic i'm here for
the systemic adventure baseball but i
didn't want dave to get in trouble but
um yes the show looks [ __ ] phenomenal
um
i will say this
i thought there's a missed opportunity
at the end of the trailer because it
ends kind of soft
where you just like do something badass
man because the first seat opens with
him being like i'm not here to be an
[ __ ] i'm here to do things right
and then you know it feels like the
bookend to that trailer is showing him
[ __ ] doing something wrong but that's
just me i was not displeased whatsoever
i loved it all but i thought it was
strange that
the last beat was the last beat i can't
remember exactly what it was but it's
more suggestive than anything else
enough because you want you want the the
oh ren ishii scene in the in in kill
bill one where it's
you are all welcome to come here today
and tell me anything you would like to
tell me i look forward to your you know
suggestions and by all means i aim for
open communication with all of my
subordinates but if any [ __ ]
brings up that point before i will take
your [ __ ] head like you just needed
that bit at the end
i love just i'm watching the show
regardless is a great trailer regardless
but
you know what about an
iconic if he beat somebody to death with
a gaffy stick at the end of that trailer
at that table where he's just like
like [ __ ] de niro and the
untouchables just throws the bat and
he's just looking around and [ __ ]
um but i'm here for the ongoing
rehabilitation of boba fett as a
character
um i mean rehabilitation [ __ ] it's like
he's finally getting his due this has
been one of the most uh beloved
characters in the star wars universe and
now everyone's going to get to bathe in
boba for a while we thought well the
mandalorian is as good as it's going to
get but [ __ ] disney plus was like
hold our beer and suddenly we're getting
an old [ __ ] boba fett mini-series go
back and tell
the kids
in 1979 who watched the star wars
christmas special where boba fett was
introduced in animated form maybe it was
1980 i'm sure banff man will correct me
if i'm wrong
go tell those kids they're gonna get a
whole boba fett mini-series one day
they'll be like
uh here for it looks great
in december yeah he was invited in and
didn't come in to [ __ ]
correct me
chris when would it be christmas 79 or
christmas 80 the star wars christmas
so i was right
nice 79.
that's twice i was right about this and
i was right about
kentucky
well the jury's out whether you were
right
enough i see a lot of people in chat
going you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
the um
i love that the trailer just popped off
with the bomar monk
which was the creature
that's why the brain creature spider
that you saw in the very background of
the
version of return of the jedi that you
had if you didn't tape it off of abc
like i did and cut that out um
you know like from that moment it was
like hey
hey you guys
this is you're gonna like this
um and then it it was interesting i was
more
intrigued by where they were going
kind of the tone and everything of the
trailer
then i was like oh my god this is the
craziest thing of all time like it felt
very i saw somebody in chat rex young
said godfather fed
and it felt very like
a little bit it and it also felt to me
like literally it takes place in the
underworld so
it felt like that was like
we're gonna give you a minute and 30
seconds out of the first 15 minutes of
the first episode
of the show
like i think that was that was all stuff
that's like right up front in that first
episode like all the exposition you need
was in that trailer
uh jay something in chat says google
says 78
kev wrong again is it christmas 78 no
when did empire strikes back come out
1980 right
yeah i came out in 1980 and the holiday
special had to have been 79.
i'm gonna google it too
um i think it's i think it's less the
godfather and more the wire
i think like
that sounds promising if uh if boba fett
is ultimately stringer bell
who's like i'm trying i'm gonna come in
i'm gonna reform it i'm gonna actually
give this crime syndicate some [ __ ]
rules and some
actual managerial pizzazz
and kill a bunch of people on the way
but if the he did it that way i'm the
next generation i'm doing it my way
it it is 1978. we both
we both
look man
as long as you've got some [ __ ] [ __ ]
the world is wrong with this native body
this [ __ ] smells like [ __ ]
like cookies like it smells like it says
it's sugar cookie i'm just rubbing this
on me i guess it's like putting soap on
your hands but
oh my god i want sugar cookies so
[ __ ] badly right now
then maybe you should put down the body
wash sir
or i should lick the body one
step
shots um so morbius the morbius is true
wait before we go to morbius let's talk
about another trailer that dropped this
week which one buzz lightyear
this looks adorable i had no idea that
this is about the real
astronaut that inspired the toy
that's how deep cuts this [ __ ] show
is and i know you know everyone's like
but wait it was tim
[ __ ] but it's not tim allen anymore
now it's it's chris
evans and and you know
this is cancelled culture
not at all it's it's just it ain't buzz
lightyear it's buzz lightyear
it's the guy
that they based the toy on so it
wouldn't necessarily be
tim allen's voice
no bam
i'm just in for the show like it looks
[ __ ] dope like it looks heartwarming
as [ __ ]
and
i love him as an actor i'll [ __ ]
listen to him be the voice of that
character it's crazy though that he'll
do be the voice of buzz lightyear but he
wouldn't be in the what-if show
but i guess it's a different thing right
he's like if i ever open my mouth
as captain america again
it's gonna be for a hundred million
dollars i want the downy yeah i want
them downy buck so instead i'll say
whatever the [ __ ] you want is buzz
lightyear you'll pay me but
but man if you want them captain america
pipes
you've got to break me off that rdj
money
which i bet they were all probably
getting by the end maybe not all but you
know everyone started
making big six i'm sure they all were
doing all right
uh george edwards and trap in chat says
never left a youtube comment but big fan
guys
please get better mics
now i don't have a mic i'm working off
the mic in my laptop
uh i imagine mark is doing the same no
mark's got an actual [ __ ] mic so
marshall's doing more than me i'm
literally just going off the lap the
laptop mic but i do
hear a lot of in chat not here but see
uh people always talk about you mark
they're like his mic sucks i assumed you
were going off the laptop no i mean
maybe i should given the actual mic that
i have doesn't seem to be doing the job
but
i didn't invest in technology
bam
because he cares oh bam fan is here to
update us on technology because mark's
in a
a glass box
all it's he sounds hollow because he's
in a empty room
is that what it is yeah and reflective
yeah
george george edwards says over 50k
views last video let's invest in the
brand i think that's very funny it's
what's fun
i'll say what's funny he goes also jc
producer and presenter two very
different roles let's stick to the
former oh
george i disagree i love when banff man
comes in uh yeah there's a few people
who really don't like me in chat every
every week even when we're doing the
show from the bar
i get like the
more of the guys less of jc like there's
always one guy who really doesn't like
me
um
but the other thing always bring you
always bring good information
the funny thing is is when i'm in chat
doing the show from the bar
there's always the people who are like
i can't hear it i'm watching it on my
phone and i can't hear it i wish you
guys would just keep doing the home
shows those sound great
so we're damned if we do
yeah we're damned if we do damned if we
don't
i mean look
i love doing the home show because i'm
like uh you're only seeing me from here
up
so you know i could [ __ ] eat
if i wanted to i'm not eating now
because i'm going out on tour soon so
i'm trying to i'm trying to
figure out myself
um but yeah home shows are [ __ ] fun
and easy as [ __ ] stuff but uh you
know there's a lot of energy to the bar
shows like an energy that obviously we
can't
get here online and stuff and it's not
like we like doing the bar shows because
we make money off it the money you make
off of that show is very very minimal
very nominal um you do it because the
energy in the room and [ __ ] you do it to
be around a bunch of people who feel the
same way you feel about this [ __ ] and
you know you make corny ass dad jokes
about [ __ ] geek material his dream
come true and [ __ ]
anyway that's not anyway everyone's like
that's we know that yeah a lot of love
for banff man though once we said that
some people don't like banff men
uh everyone jumping in to be like i love
jc bamf i like him banff man needs a
comic book jc is cool you're getting all
the love man
um
he is as well he deserves
um
dan perth asks thoughts on the eternals
reviews
uh is that one of our news stories um it
isn't um
primarily because i would like to see
the movie first before we start talking
too much about it good point good point
we can talk about the newsworthy item
that this is the first marvel movie that
has dipped below
the fresh rating on rotten tomatoes that
seemed to be the big story this week
everyone's like
shudder like it went lower than thor the
thor two the dark world and then you
look at thor two and their scores like i
don't know 66 or something something
where i'm like hey man as a guy i made
yoga hosers i wish i was thor too
[Laughter]
but apparently eternal i don't know if
it's still there but it dipped below the
60 mark and that
that sent a thousand people writing on
the internet obviously
yeah i mean i think there's
uh it's it's a gamble for marvel i
not having seen it yet i don't know how
successful it is or it isn't
but it would not surprise me
if the same kind of review bombing that
goes on
for films uh that have a quote-unquote
woke message
or
filmmakers of color or filmmakers that
are female or
you know characters who are
may or may not have incurred the wrath
of the same people
who coordinatedly [ __ ] on stuff
um um boy
i would hate to be in that position i
wonder what that's like
you know you know how that goes um
i i mean i'm going to see this [ __ ]
movie we tried to go see we're gonna go
see it uh monday with good old brett
deacon man uh at 40 x and they were
willing and we were willing but the way
they do these preview screenings is they
got to send a security person with with
this to watch the flick like somebody
from the studio
like you know the content cop or
whatever the [ __ ] has to be there to
make sure that you're not shooting it
with your iphone or whatever the [ __ ] so
they didn't have somebody they they
didn't schedule that person so we didn't
get to go see it
you know it ain't a big deal the movie's
coming out friday correct
i'll be at the rhode island comic-con
which is a wonderful place as any to see
a comic book movies or perhaps i'll take
it in
in the beautiful but tiny state of rhode
island the tiny beautiful state of rhode
island
um but uh yeah we we were trying to see
it this weekend
i mean this month monday but it didn't
pan out for us
um i have not read any of the reviews um
there's some stuff that's hard to avoid
on twitter and whatnot but
um
you know
sooner or later somebody's got to be the
lowest scorer
you know it looks like
what i've seen of the reviews it's it's
not
you know people attacking
like the wokeness or the cast it's like
it's people going like and it's not
they're not attacking obviously those
are just people writing reviews
uh people citing the length and and uh
as like you know
the detriment or something like that
um also like you know you don't have
well i don't know these three but i
heard a spider-man you know and i know
captain america and [ __ ] thor like
they're gonna introduce us to a brand
new team of characters and
you know
you got to be a pretty hardcore comic
book aficionado marvel aficionado jack
kirby aficionado to like be well versed
in the eternals is my humble opinion i'm
sure somebody out there will be like
[ __ ] you the eternals is life and i'm
like great fantastic
the guy who's been reading comics for a
damn minute 51 years old like
you know they were far outside of
the books that i was reading now
so was guardians of the galaxy
and
the you know they they took that and
[ __ ] turned it into something that
like i'll
[ __ ] go to my grave saying this is
one of the greatest movies ever [ __ ]
made that and the sequel
um
so it's not to be said that like you
know just because i don't know the book
or i don't like the book doesn't mean
that they can't turn it into a thing
that becomes wonderful and stuff so
you know
i i'm i'm like you i'm ready to take it
all in man i mean i'll go for the right
director chloe and and
and uh you know there's they look like
they're trying something different in
terms of the look like hey let's shoot
outside and [ __ ] like that and it's
marvel it's got the marvel name on it
and kevin foggy
gave it a blessing so i got you know
i've liked everything he's done so far i
can't imagine
that um you know i won't like this so
yeah
i'll buy the ticket go for the ride
we'll see what we get exactly man
and you know if this marvel don't
make my day
if i wait 10 minutes spider-man's about
to swing on by and
yep
absolutely but yeah all right but anyway
back to the news back to the news so
light year looks really good um morbius
looks like a lot of movie
yeah let's talk about that morbid
trailer
um my you know i i tease it because my
god if they said marvel once it seems
like they said a thousand marvel's
newest this marvel wait till you see
what marvel has of its sleep
marvelous this guy is he's a vampire but
he's a marvel vampire
you know they're laying into the
pedigree and rightfully so it's not like
morbius is an insanely well-known
character um outside of hardcore comic
book fandom um you know
i'll see it
yeah i mean it's it feels very much like
it's
it's one of those classic marvel origins
which is
what if it was doctor strange but with
uh well but as a vampire
but what if it was tony stark but as a
vampire like
you know rich dude you know injures
himself i've got to heal myself i'll use
the power of i don't know nature right
you know i will go to the lengths of the
world to discover the cure to my you
know ailment which will then turn me
into something extra human and in this
case the living vampire
jared leto is uh easy to love and easy
to tease um but he is a good actor
yeah he's not he's not half stepping it
and he looks like he's invested his you
know i he
is his joker take obviously is you know
not
as preferred as the heath ledger take or
the joaquin phoenix take and whatnot but
the guy he does a whole lot of acting in
whatever he does he always commits yeah
and and you know you saw him in the
gucci trailer he's unrecognizable he
likes to play with the makeup too guy
that pretty likes to disappear in the
makeup and stuff
um you know he seems game i'm there this
ain't his first comic book movie he's in
his first rodeo obviously
um
and uh you know if you'd have told me
when i was a kid they're gonna do a
morbius movie one day and be like what
what will they do werewolf by night next
and perhaps they will perhaps they will
but um and the money sony really
expanding their spider-verse aren't they
they are they are doing their best to
tie it all in
also like and being self-referential
[ __ ] morbius makes a venom joke he
does i'm better nah just kidding i'm dr
morbius the internet was like all this
morning twitter was like what the [ __ ]
universe is this taking place in because
you know the vultures there from from
mcu
but the daily bugle is the peter the the
sam raimi spider-man
in that newspaper they reference the
rhino and black cat
um which would be
you know the andrew garfield universe i
guess
they had a rhino yeah um and uh what
else there was some other thing where
they're like wait a sec what [ __ ]
universe is this oh the poster of
spider-man wanted is
sam raimi's spider-man right not the tom
holland one so
uh you know they've not made it clear
yet
which exact universe is taking place in
perhaps things will be more clear after
uh spider-man no way home
yeah i mean i don't i also don't know
how much longer
the marvel sony partnership
um
or agreement continues like i thought it
was for three movies
um three solo spider-man movies so you
get your spider-man homecoming your
spider-man far from home and your
spider-man no way home well no then they
had that big blow remember after the
last movie it was like oh looks like
they're [ __ ] not going to work
together again but then they
healed all wounds and i i thought it was
for longer than that they'd be silly
not to [ __ ] continue
consulting with one another like you
know we love it we hate separate
universes we love that [ __ ]
you know venom can now pop up in [ __ ]
uh the mcu and stuff they they should
make nice and always [ __ ]
keep things as is man yeah i mean that's
my hot take give me what i want i think
i speak for all the internet when i say
give me exactly what i want whatever it
is at any given time
yeah i mean we'll see we'll see all of
these things are always in flux and
there's never any real telling what
giant corporations with
run by people with giant egos will do
um
but
but um i mean i'll see it because i see
all of these things except for venom two
i haven't seen that yet
um maybe i'll catch up with it before
boy that's making all the money and [ __ ]
yeah
no it uh it it mystifies me how well
it's doing
um because i don't know about the second
one it doesn't mystify me anymore once i
realize once the internet told me it was
pg-13 i was like oh of course
like you could take a kid to this it's
just naughty enough but he ain't doing
real killing there ain't no carnage
going on in that [ __ ] thing yeah and
that ain't a complaint don't [ __ ] you
know kevin smith says there ain't no
carnage in carnage and [ __ ] i'm just
saying
it can make that kind of money because
it's a pg-13 movie man with a whiff of
naughtiness to it so and you know tom
hardy is amazing who don't want to
[ __ ] see that dude act i'll watch
that dude
act in in anything man watch that dude
do any role
i watch that dude do me
i mean sell tickets they got a camera on
it and [ __ ] i'm looking at the camera
and he's behind me i'm watching him
you're upset like a younger man he's
even good at this
[Laughter]
boy they don't call him hardy for
nothing yeah
let me get some of that darkness
um
i was born oh i was born in it
i didn't see the light until i was in my
bed by then it was blinding
um all right what other news
um
there was uh i suppose it was when eva
duvernay
was doing interviews in support of of
her new netflix show
about uh colin kaepernick she did an
interview with with andy cohen and uh
and talked about the reason why her new
gods movie
was taken off of the release slate
and
her now yes her conjecture is according
according to her
um
she says the warner brothers killed new
gods because
quote the studio decided that they did
not want to pursue a certain part of
that comic book world based on some
things that were going on with another
film in that world so before i was able
to kind of complete my script with tom
king they asked it
so the prevailing theory had been
that the snyder cut was the reason why
new gods went away because the snyder
cut brings in
all of the new gods ultimately not all
of them but a decent chunk of them you
get your dark side you get your granny
goodness you get all of that stuff
and so
her feeling and her conjecture
apparently
is that
the reason why they wouldn't go forward
is because schneiderverse kind of stole
that glory
um
and she said this out loud
i mean all she said was there were some
things going on with another film in
that world
can't imagine these comments went over
well with uh
the snyder verse folks the folks
release the snyder cup folks you know i
i i could not tell you i tend to not
truck down those particular blind alleys
of the internet
um
but it wouldn't surprise me either
um how accurate do you think it is as a
director's conjecture uh how accurate do
you think it is um
you know i think
of of anybody who is poised to know
she's among them
you know yeah i mean listen to me i'm
like come on hacker could this be what
does she know mark
i guess she was kind of close to the
situation
um
well i mean you know that then
don't be mad at her be mad at [ __ ]
others he didn't do it yeah but being
like yeah maybe we shouldn't do this
twice i i would
i i was looking
forward to that like in in a weird way
i'm not the biggest new gods fan but i
have a lot of respect for
kirby's uh fourth world characters uh
and and and also the spirit under with
which they were created this is when he
broke away from marvel and came over to
dc and kind of gave dc its greatest uh
bad guy a cosmic bad guy dark side for
heaven's sakes
so i was looking forward to it and ava
is incredibly talented and watching
uh someone of her stature and
storytelling stature tell a [ __ ]
story about
big barta
[ __ ] mr miracle scot-free [ __ ]
high father [ __ ] light ray
my [ __ ]
orion look at me look at me busting all
the
names i was ready for that movie man so
that's a bummer that warner brothers is
like no they had enough of [ __ ] darks
up no they're all the mother boxes they
needed yeah no yeah no i would like a
few more mother boxes i would love to
see that [ __ ] new gods movie
um you know but then again you know i
watch all these [ __ ] movies so
they're not they're not counting on me
they're like we know you're coming
you need other people to give a [ __ ] but
i don't see why they don't think people
wouldn't give a [ __ ] well told story
classic [ __ ] characters
again one of the greatest cosmic bad
guys of all [ __ ] time and [ __ ] [ __ ]
in a world where marvel made thanos work
like
you don't think somebody can make dark
side work zach did in [ __ ] you know
zack snyder's justice league how about
giving us more of that world man [ __ ]
we got we got to see a little bit of
granny goodness
a little bit of decide let's see what
that would look like even if it's you
know different versions than what zach's
would have been like those are great
characters stand the test of time
hopefully warner brothers like you know
counters at one point they're like you
know what
i mean in a world of like all the
content all the [ __ ]
channels they got to fill not just their
film slate but hbo max and stuff you
mean to tell me there ain't
some [ __ ] iteration of new gods they
can't get going
come on i mean i wonder if
if
however the eternals does will be a bit
of a bellwether
you know because again like cosmic
characters created by jack kirby that
nobody's overly familiar with
given the shine
of a big-ass marvel release cast to
within its inch of its life
um directed by an an a oscar lauded
female filmmaker
maybe it's
all right
let's see and let me tell you something
mark bernardin oh [ __ ] world is blind
you wearing bifocals i didn't even
[ __ ] see that angle you're right
somebody
might have been like let's just put a
pin in this until we see how
eternals does because
i find this to be similar and stuff
you're right it's a comp and in a world
in which the studios are always looking
for what is this like what does it feel
like what would give me it could be a
competition they didn't have one for new
gods just like they didn't have one for
eternals and now at least you know new
gods has one in the way of eternals
that's interesting i hadn't thought of
that
so but yeah i would i would like to see
this movie i would like to see
especially you know tom king co-writing
it with her you know to see the movie
that the two of them would have come up
with would be interesting a good joke is
a good joke a-z atheist and chad said
new gods how about no
no gods no kings no gods no rules that's
a bummer man
no big barta
big martyr man is a great character
[ __ ] scot-free
is a is an amazing character
and tom king was going to be writing
this thing with her right mm-hmm
oh you mean that tom king
this [ __ ] award-winning book
indeed
you know what they should just do a mr
miracle that [ __ ] book was fantastic
he's a great character um but i i want i
want my new gods movie mark i was
promised one
yeah we're told was gonna come but
sadly
[ __ ]
what else is going on
um uh chris pratt
continues to dominate
um all italian related voice work
he is now going to be the voice of the
lasagna loving monday meeting garfield
you consider garfield italian he's all
about that lasagna
he likes the lasagna but he always come
across kind of waspy to me
an old kind of over it
all of his complaints are first world
problems very
uh but wow wait chris pratt is doing
another cartoon voice not he's not just
mario now he's garfield as well he
apparently is hollywood's go-to voice
actor
and so
okay twitter lit up today saying uh it
was a real
you know hey man if you can't get jack
black then you go to chris pratt and a
lot of like
you know uh jack black could have been
in
you know [ __ ] uh
school of rock no no jack black could
have been in
guardians of the galaxy but
chris pratt never could have been in
school of rock [ __ ] like that
unfair to compare the two jack black is
a [ __ ] icon a legend and chris pat is
iconic and legendary in his own way
although he has kind of views that are
different than mine but
that's neither here nor there but like i
i like i loved him as in the lego movie
i thought it was an adorable
voice over there but uh i don't know
that i hear
him when i i don't know i hear garfield
when i see you hear him talk he's too
nice garfield's kind of shitty yeah and
he's too energetic
like like bill murray in many ways was a
great garfield
you know right attitude right [ __ ]
voice just
you know you can't give a [ __ ] chris
crack sounds like he gives a [ __ ]
we know he gives a [ __ ] i had a heart
attack and the dude like tweeted like i
will be praying for you i never you know
it's not like we know each other so very
nice guys you know i'm not saying an
actor can't act but
i don't i don't think of him as a
finicky cat at all
banff
oh
it's always exciting when batman has
something to add go i hear harrison ford
in garfield
uh you know i want with lasagna it's
another case of the mondays i just want
to i know like in the bed today where's
odie
that sounds dangerously close to ralph
garman's uh [ __ ]
od
yeah um you're right he is kind of uh
low-energy [ __ ] and [ __ ] but
garfield's got them bright eyes you know
harrison ford
you don't have them bright eyes and not
anymore he's got them soulful eyes and
[ __ ] yeah i don't know i there's
something about garfield that always
struck me is like he's like 60 65 years
old like he's an old cat he's not no
spring chicken he's he's on his way to
whatever place cats go when they die
yeah what about tracy morgan there's a
good garfield
i yeah i was gonna say thing reigns
would be an amazing garfield
tracy tracy morgan's garfield would
constantly threaten to get you pregnant
i'm gonna get you pregnant this lemon
and when a cat gets you pregnant there's
gonna be there's a lot of kittens we
know that they don't have one it's a
whole litter
one of my favorite jokes of all time and
i still remember it to this day
is from 30 rock when he says uh you know
i mean i made a remake of affair to
remember and then you start in your head
doing all the joke titles for it it's
like it was called a feather remember
well fair to remember like yes
perfect
so yeah but hey chris pratt is making
[ __ ] garfield and mario brothers so
you know he must know more than we do
i mean look never mind the chris proud
of it all let's just let's just top at
the garfield at all this is still
happening this [ __ ] cat
i mean it seems as if also garfield is
this garfield's from the 80s do you
remember like garfield got popular when
we were kids
i mean garfield started in 1978.
garfield is you know almost
50 years old
and people are still like oh that
[ __ ] saucy cat oh he's got a lot of
lip on him that cow i love to hear him
give [ __ ] to his owner my favorite
version of garfield when i was a kid i
absolutely loved garfield don't get me
wrong i collected all the books and [ __ ]
but currently as a grown-up my favorite
incarnation of garfield was garfield
without garfield that online comic where
they just moved garfield it's a series
of john talking to himself existential
dread of john without a cat
now that's some [ __ ] funny [ __ ] right
there i mean um also htg movie nobody
does 2d animation anymore this must be a
live action a cg cat in a live action
world or
i mean gonna be [ __ ] cg
the the last two garfield movies were
live action animation hybrids
um i have to imagine at this point it's
probably just all cg because do we
really need to see real people in all
this
big
t1377 says we need that heathcliff yeah
man [ __ ] let's cross those two
[ __ ] over let's see a cat fight
garfield vs heathcliff man and one of
them's like you're the k-mart version of
me but which one's which
oh see now that you now i'm interested
yeah if it's the [ __ ] warring orange
cats
you know it's west side story but with
orange cats boring orange cat
[Music]
it's a musical when you're a cat you're
a cat from your first cigarette your
last iron
the gang was called the cats i take it
pretty much yes rogers and hammerstein's
garfield versus heathcliff a tale of two
kitties
[Laughter]
um all right goodbye uh good for that
[ __ ] guy boy he's getting all the
work and [ __ ] how come nobody calls me
and says hey man be garfield
i mean not for nothing you'd be a better
garfield than chris pratt because
garfield is also clearly stoned
all the time that cat is high on catnip
like a [ __ ] and so all he wants to do
is eat and sleep and it's a monday again
this is [ __ ] where's my food where's
my nip let me tell you something i'm
just [ __ ] i stopped on [ __ ] i
would i'm better than chris pratt thank
you very much yes see look dear
hollywood
come on
come on when you make your heathcliff
movie
call a homie
yeah that's what i'll get they're like
you can have heathcliff
you can have top cat like what okay
make that work good luck pal funny boy
jay and silly bob
you don't go near garfield that's chris
pratt country
you're heathcliff all the way we're
gonna push you off that heath cliff
and scene well done
um all right
let's uh let's uh move on to
other news other news
did uh there was almost an elf two
once upon a time i saw this news this
week tell us but apparently it was awful
um so awful so awful that will ferrell
turned down 29 million dollars which was
the offer to make elf too
um he says the decisions walk away was
simple
i would have had to promote the movie
from an honest place which would have
been like oh no it's not good
i just couldn't turn down that much
money and i thought can i actually say
those words i don't think i can so i
guess i can't do the movie
um
so yeah apparently imagine let me let's
just stop for a minute imagine having
that kind of integrity
i don't know what that's like
oh my god if somebody offered me 29
bucks to do elf 2 i'd be like done
where's my pointy shoes even if they're
like the script is dog [ __ ] i'm like you
kidding me people can go see it anyway
man may not make as much the last one
and sure i'll be in the lesser elf but
i'll be in an elf picture
i'll put that on my grave here lie
silent bob he was in an elf picture not
the one everyone liked but still dot dot
dot
um wow good for good for will he must be
doing very well
if you could turn down 29 million
dollars i mean and also we don't know
when this was but clearly it wasn't like
last year so it was earlier in his
career because elf two
elf one broke in big and so at some
point they were like we want to do it
again buddy we want to do it again
and he's like not with this one this is
a honking piece of [ __ ]
i will i will not pay off anybody's uh
retirement homes with this
i don't mean to uh
uh brag mark but i
have directed a will ferrell in my
career
uh yes i've seen such pictures 20 years
back
my finger
was on this pulse um yes he's a lovely
[ __ ] dude very fun on set as you
would imagine um very very uh funny
funny ad libber um
what else we got
um this story tickled me um and at first
i was like is this in our wheelhouse but
then i remembered
um you can make it work i can make it
work
jason tudekis and rosario dawson are
leading a virtual live reading of the
great supernatural
holiday classic it's a wonderful life i
just saw this she had it in her
instagram feed
um who's doing this it's for the ed
asner theater or some sort of [ __ ] yeah
the ed asner family center which
promotes mental health and enrichment
programs to children with special needs
in their families
um it's a one night only event on
december 5th which is a cast that
includes rosario dawson mark hamill
martin sheen mandy patinkin lou diamond
phillips phil lamarr ben mankiewicz ron
functions ed harris
and george wendt
um there's a couple of people on that
list i've worked with yeah um the cheers
actor who uh george went is actually
jason siddakis's real-life uncle
is playing uncle billy to jason
sudeikis's george bailey wait what jesus
jake is what real life one george wendt
is jason sudeikis's uncle
they're related
really
yeah
and so george wendt is going to play
uncle billy to jason sedegas's george
bailey i mean that's the the biggest
takeaway from this is like jason zudegas
his uncle is norm
how's it going norm well great because
my nephew is jason sedakis and [ __ ]
ted lasso was an amazing show i mean i
guess look i'm no cheers writer so
clearly that wasn't tricky enough
because i win an emmy and move on to
[ __ ] frasier nothing like that
but actually if you look at pictures of
like sudaikus and george went especially
when wendt was younger like oh yeah that
is a bit of a family resemblance i mean
that's crazy to me but like one it's not
like one helped the other you know what
i'm saying like
like to the best of my knowledge now
yeah and i mean how could he like other
than george went was on snl a couple
times but it's not like he was a you
know hey put my nephew in this [ __ ]
show that ain't the way that show works
and [ __ ] it's just weird when you find
out
famous successful people
are related
that
you never would have known it because
it's not like oh yeah george went gave
him a leg up
right i think it's one of those and you
hear those stories that clooney's talked
about it quite a bit that is a mother's
rosemary clooney who was a big ass
[ __ ] song and dance sort of musical
theater star for a while right and it's
like it's less that rosemary
my mom helped me but i got to live the
life of a child of an entertainer and so
i got to see some of hollywood from the
inside and know what people were going
through and knowing you know that there
were values instilled because my parents
lived through it that i was able to take
with me and i think sudaikis was like
yeah i occasionally would visit my uncle
when he was on set or when he was in
town doing appearances or whatever but
that
the insight into the business
might help a young you know aspirant
learn to navigate it a little bit better
a little bit earlier and not make the
dumb mistakes that people do make when
they get rich and or famous
um
man oh man that's uh
i'm still kind of like what those guys
are related when is that reading when is
that and is it free or you gotta buy
tickets it is uh december 5th you do
have to buy tickets tickets start at 25
bucks
um that also apparently comes with a
commemorative holiday gift item
um and there's a
worth it uh yeah so it's 5 p.m pacific
standard on sunday december 5th
i'm sure if you searched for the
ed asner family center and or sudeikisen
it's a wonderful life you'll find a link
somewhere on the internet
chat very funny tonight as they're all
going like uh i hear ethan cohen has a
brother
like
yes his name is roderick haynes steve
corton says that's like finding out joe
rogan and gerard way are cousins they
are that was crazy when i found that out
i was like
um rosemary clooney was george's aunt uh
bicky's restorations is saying ah my bad
not mom but yeah he had a famous
relative yeah
and uh and yes mr marcy or ms marcy it
is a charity livestream you pay for
otherwise they don't raise money for
charity
rosemary clooney is george
clooney's aunt
miguel ferrer
was rosemary's son so mel ferreira and
rosemary clooney had miguel ferreira you
know
albert in twin peaks amongst many things
he was in our world
he was the vice president i believe in
iron man 3.
indeed and he was also uh the young
upstart salesman in robocop yes yeah he
was the one that was like you're my
[ __ ] man that guy oh
him as albert and twin peaks is one of
my favorite [ __ ]
performances of all time like the the uh
the the guy the forensics guy who was
just so [ __ ] shitty
he come into the small town and calls
them all rubes and hicks and [ __ ] oh he
was so [ __ ] good and jose ferreira
was the pedosha emperor yeah he was the
emperor who we haven't even met yet in
in [ __ ] denny vilnews movie and [ __ ]
um
how do you say
emperor
iv
shaddaam iv
that pissy little [ __ ] he sent the
harkonnens against
[ __ ] house atreides because he's a
he's a he's a
uh what do they call him
not jealous man scary no jealous man
he's a jealous man he's a petty jealous
man
[ __ ] jerk yeah
uh
what other news whether or not
our last story is about a dead man
however
it is not a sad one we are celebrating
the 94th birthday of steve ditko
the artist and co-creator along with
stan lee of spider-man and doctor
strange and the uh without stanley uh
soul creator i believe of the question
indeed along with the
blue beetle and the creeper shade the
changing man hawk and dove oh my god
you're right i forgot he did shade as
well and creeper creeper is a [ __ ]
wonderful looking character um but he
was an artist and writer correct
indeed um i think he he he broke in for
the most part his biggest creations were
as an artist but he did it both artists
writer
like he was the guy that kind of created
this doctor strange universe like
and i think stan started with like his
name's doctor strange and stuff but i
believe most of the other stuff
came from ditko you're wrong but yeah
like jormamu i believe is his
yeah you know and he he contributed a
bunch to marvel comics until 1966
when he left marvel for unclear reasons
never been
never been actually revealed although
one can assume
it was either over money and or credit
and or you know
sort of being able to captain his own
[ __ ]
and then went to tarleton and dc and did
a bunch of work until he passed away
about four years ago
um yeah his recently his brother was in
the news because they're like we're
gonna get ours man
going after marvel and getting our
[ __ ] spider-man copyright back
trademarked back
so sooner or later the good folks at
disney will probably have to
come to some sort of financial agreement
with the ditko estate why won't they yes
i hope they do and i hope it doesn't
become some ugly drawn out legal battle
that
ends up in tears
um
because nobody wants that
nobody wants that
um you've been watching foundation
there's a lot of foundation
chatter
i have not yet um i i did start midnight
mass though on netflix which i'm liking
quite a bit it is uh it is not too scary
for this here wuss yeah tell me sell me
on midnight mass everyone keeps trying
to but you you might actually succeed
you know it's it reminds me very much of
a stephen king story in that it's set in
some like you know coastal island what
is probably off the coast of maine
because it feels like it
um in which there's this very small
tightly knit community full of people
who all know each other's business and
uh and the priest the the father of the
parish who've been there for
you know
75 years
has gone missing and so there's a
replacement um priest who shows up and
that sort of kicks off what seems to be
a vampire story
what seems to be a story about sort of
recovery and alcoholism and
responsibility
um a story about faith the story about
um
sort of desperation and despondence
um it's it's a slow burn for sure you
know in the same way that your great
stephen king stories are like let me
introduce you to these people and let me
get you inside their lives and then let
me drop something supernatural into it
and see how they respond um
but uh the cast is great you know i'm in
love with you know i mean i've been in
love with robert coley for a while but
he was a he was a guest on
in your absence but he plays a muslim
sheriff in an overwhelmingly christian
town
and you know sort of the the navigating
that
trying to be a man of authority
when he sees his his own authority being
undercut at almost every turn
um and i don't know the actor's name but
he was matt saracen on friday night
blights
but um but he seems to be the other
because it's an ensemble piece but he
seems to be the other lead and he's
doing he's doing haunted very very well
um it's beautiful the production values
are great
um and it seems to have like one or two
decent sort of shock scares an episode
um i'm four deep so i don't know how it
resolves other than
i know that
there's a vampire involved um spoilers
but there's a vampire involved um but
how you get to vampire and who the
vampire is it's all fascinating so yeah
i recommend it
um
uh
um june i rewatched it yeah life because
she hadn't seen it
um and i i i i again it's a lot like i
didn't enjoy it the first time but i
like she didn't remember the david lynch
tune i was like [ __ ] we watched
it together
i don't remember this story and she
[ __ ] went for a hook line and sinker
man the visuals like brought her in
and you know the [ __ ] intrigue and
all that [ __ ] but she was like all over
it
um and then you know felt like she had
the [ __ ] rug pulled out from under
she was like
what it's just over and i was like yeah
yeah that's how he rolls he just [ __ ]
stops they go for a walk in credits man
that's all
lord of the rings all over again but uh
she was way down with it and then
watching it the second time like i
i didn't i didn't i didn't bump into
anything the first time except i was
like i wish we heard their thoughts like
in the lynch version
but i i liked it quite a bit like i was
able to sit through it again and i
wasn't like
ugh you know honestly
like the first time i went to sit down
and watch it like when about 20 minutes
in occurred to me like holy [ __ ] we're
literally just gonna watch the same
movie it's just a better looking version
and [ __ ]
i didn't have that feeling when i
watched this it wasn't like i want to
watch dune again i was it was fun to
watch it with somebody who was like
drinking it in like and really digging
it and stuff
yeah i think there's
the thing that i loved about the lynch
version especially seeing why i saw it
was it was the first film in which i was
lost
in that i didn't really know what was
happening and i didn't really get the
context for everything and that desire
to kind of like go back in and dig deep
and watch it again and what the [ __ ] is
happening so to read up about it it's
the first movie that ever did that for
me
and i think there is a virtue in that in
and we don't get it very much anymore
but coming to a film that you know
nothing about and just sort of
surrender yourself to it in a way
and i'm somewhat jealous of your your
average normie who knows nothing about
dude who comes to it and becomes seduced
by it because it is that was yeah he was
just like you know i was like what do
you mean you don't remember this story
[ __ ] he sticks his hand in a box and
[ __ ] you remember this and she's like
not at all and she's a big reader but
she never read tune so she really like
it just enveloped her it was kind of
interesting to watch i was like right on
man like it's nice to see sci-fi work
really well and it's not like oh she
poopoos that [ __ ] like she's way into
sci-fi as the next guy and stuff but
like
it what he went to achieve what he
wanted to achieve
for the audience he absolutely achieved
with her hands down she took the exact
ride that he wanted her
to take so much so that i was like hey
shouldn't he at least
consult her husband before he takes her
on this [ __ ] ride that she enjoys so
much
yeah she was she was she was down like a
clown for it man yeah um what about uh
the foundation i did i did by the end of
the movie memorize the [ __ ] uh name
shy well done sir
last time i was like i'm never going to
remember this [ __ ] name
is coming we are blessed by his coming
and going
it's still the funnest [ __ ] thing to
say is quit zack thadder rock
there's a lot of fun words in them yeah
there's a lot of fun words that's a big
word from messiah quid zak saddle rock
you couldn't just break it down to
the bene jesuit sisterhood
yeah they're so [ __ ] full of
themselves they really are there's been
they know best nuns and [ __ ] they've
been told to bear only daughters i know
[ __ ] you i'll
bear what i want
and a treaty's daughter could have been
bringed to a harkonnened sun and we
would have controlled the offspring i
love when marked nerds out get him some
skywalker wine
deeper
um by the juice of sabu you did my
thoughts require speed and my lips
acquire stained was that in the book or
was that just in lynch it's in the book
that's in the book they didn't do that
and uh
the men touch really got sidelined in
this version of it
you know you know what that means what
are the men what's the mensa the mentats
were um
this mulchin plays the baron that guy
who brad doroth played right and they're
the human computers because this is a
this is a somewhat analog world there
had been some kind of computer rhythm
and their eyes go white and they could
come up with figures right loofah is
that in uh through for howit is that for
the the treaty so every great house has
a mentat that just does all of that
grinding computing um to just spit out
figures in data and analysis because
there's no computers i like that yeah
they they didn't they they took that
[ __ ] you know i what is it that you
know yeah the juice of sabu by by my
will alone do i set my mind in motion by
the juice of sabu do my thoughts acquire
speed do my lips acquire staying um by
my will alone do i set my mind in motion
you're so lucky you're already married
because you've not gotten any chances of
getting laid back
that's not a penny dropper you don't
think if i just roll into it what if i
rolled into scum and villainy and it was
like i need juice for my lips i have
these stuffs got to acquire speed
i don't think so
i don't know
error nobody's walking in any place
going i need juice for my lips
um all right is that all the news that's
all the news my friend hey you wanted
the news mark gave you the news and give
him thanks
sing a new song unto the lord because
mark gave you the news ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
i um
kevin
suze vera says kevin pronounces dune
space gibberish like a six-year-old and
on the airport the kwidzak sana yes the
stains become a warning yes no unit i
forgot the stains victim a warning
um
folks if you're just joining us uh this
deep in the show
um i am heading out on the road this
week tomorrow i'm going to be showing my
movie clerk the documentary about my
life in austin at the paramount theater
tickets available at csmod.com if you're
anywhere in texas come see me uh then
i'm going to the rhode island comic con
on friday
uh and with a bunch of folks from clerks
jeff anderson brian o'halleran jason
muse everybody
i'm taking pictures doing a panel that's
on saturday
then on uh friday rather saturday i'm
going to jersey to show clerk at
smodcastle but that's sold out but
sunday i'm going to st louis you
anywhere near missouri
st lou that arch
i'm going to be at the pageant showing
clerk with malcolm ingram doing a q a
afterwards and then i go to chicago do
it at the music box theater on monday
then i go to toronto and do at the queen
elizabeth theater uh on uh tuesday and
then uh thursday i'm in vancouver at the
rio doing the show tickets at
seasmod.com if you want to come out and
see me man i've plugged my stuff because
we're about to plug our second
sponsor of the evening laser gym that's
right an embarrassment of riches here on
fat man beyond we're a name that's
trusted
in geek podcasting so much so that not
only are the good people at native
letting us
um god damn it that smells good uh
letting us uh sing their praises as our
sponsor we have a secondary sponsor
ladies and gentlemen second half of this
show is sponsored by the good folks
at blue chew
oh yes
yes you want to fill up the stocking
tell them what blue chew do mark
um i will not read their copy because
their copy is a bit uh outdated um it's
it's summer camping season let's talk
about pitching tents nope it's winter
it's cuffing season it's stocking season
it's candy cane season let's talk about
keeping that candy cane long and strong
that's right man
blue chew is a unique service that
offers and delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost take them anytime day or night you
can plan ahead but be ready whenever an
opportunity arises process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
a prescription within days
all done online no visits to a doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy and
these tablets are made in the usa
prepared and shipped direct to your door
in a discrete package what what kind of
magical
jetsons-like future do we live in mark
where you can
choose some candy
and get [ __ ] rock hard man
make life
with the with the your lifebringer
your indeed i mean amazing if george
jetson had this there would have been
more than judy and elroy i'll tell you
that much he would have had a lot of
kids a whole lot of flock of jetsons no
doubt it wouldn't been spacely yelling
his name it would have been [ __ ] jane
going johnson
get in here and he would have been like
oh gladly and he pops the [ __ ]
blue chew and
giggity let's go just goes to town man
like in the future up in the air they're
having sex in the air mark that's what
the jetsons was all about at the end of
the day people that [ __ ] up in the air
that's some barbarella [ __ ] if i ever
heard it truly man that's what blue chew
wants for you they want to put your dick
in the future where everything is good
and strong
blue shoe
gentlemen
eat it and it's going to make you erect
[ __ ] what
what more do you want in a product
if you want your sandworm to perform
better
blue chews the spice
oh
look at that and we always blow up the
copywriters over bluetooth but mark
that's some strong copy right there you
gotta know your audience so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform bluetooth can help and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code fat man at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping there's
bluetooth.com promo code fatman to
receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank the good folks of blue chew for
sponsoring this podcast let me tell you
something man not only do i thank the
good folks of blue chew for sponsoring
fat man beyond man i [ __ ] salute the
good folks at blue chew what a great
idea they're like [ __ ] taking a pill
what if we made it fun you ate it
what if we brought it to your door what
if he just brought you the thing you
want most yeah what if we took all the
doctory [ __ ] out of it and just made it
[ __ ] fun like sex should be man
eating candy and getting laid that's my
life that's what i want put that on my
headstone all he wanted was to eat candy
and get laid
sometimes [ __ ] worked out for him cause
his bar was low here lies the lowest bar
ever [ __ ] raised
a humble [ __ ] with a stiff ass
dick
changing my twitter handle to that
um all right kids uh we gave you the
news
now it's time for the nudes that's right
a new section of the show who's naked
this week on family and beyond
uh no we're gonna do uh the q a yes
first q would be like why did you think
that was an appropriate joke to make kev
my answer is i'm sorry um i'm a little
bit high yeah i'm a little tired but hi
i'm way high man i've been smoking i'm
not no but what i've been smoking here
on camera is cbd weed kids
but i have been enjoying this mighty
kind movie seltzer man which is cannabis
seltzer mark
[ __ ] cannabis what's it do for you
quenches my thirst and reminds me that i
created a character that is now on soda
cans
everybody wins
co-created the artist who originally
drew movie named scott purcell has a
cameo in clerks 3. oh nice you'll notice
him because he's wearing a movie's
jacket
branding
he was the guy that i was like uh you
know the script for called for this
movie thing
and um
you know he drew a lot of like cartoon
cows and i was like
he should look like mickey mouse
and and he was like oh that's easy and
he literally just drew a mickey mouse
cow
and i was like
and mind you we miramax was owned by
disney at the time so this was very
fed man you know
but then i saw years later tim burton's
dumbo and i was like oh my god never
mind that [ __ ] this guy like [ __ ]
[ __ ] in disney's mouth
on disney's dime making a disney movie
and they still made fun of disney and
[ __ ] it was crazy like you like it some
[ __ ] in your mouth yeah never say that
he ain't a brave filmmaker that was
crazy
um michael keaton in a wonderful
performance speaking of wonderful
performance and michael keaton and
earlier rosario dawson
watch dope sick on hulu i keep hearing
that should i
un-fucking believably good man
unbelievably good so
everyone top-notch storytelling page
turning top-notch cast is [ __ ]
wonderful michael keaton like
just
you know you're sitting there going like
i think i know everything you could do
and then you remember this [ __ ]
that was in clean and sober
so for the first time since clean and
sober he's doing
an addiction thing and it is so [ __ ]
hauntingly believable he's so good in it
rosario's good whole [ __ ] cast is
really great man it's definitely worth a
watch awesome okay not john oriented but
like you know still well done it's
depressing though heads up like yeah
it's not cheery i it no yeah it like it
made me sad too because jason muse got
caught up in that back then and back
then i remember being the guy being like
just stop [ __ ] taking these pills
grow up
this [ __ ] was insidious man they like
[ __ ] literally designed this to trap
folk so like to mint
addicts like it is these sackler people
are [ __ ] villains man so yeah it's
definitely worth a watch i mean you know
in a world where it's like that's not
really very genre oriented tell you what
richard sackler one of the biggest super
villains you'll ever [ __ ] see worse
than thanos ladies and gentlemen
at least according to this uh you know
dramatic uh mini series but i also
watched you know the hbo dock and the
sackler folks don't come off very well
in that either [ __ ] such greed man
it's like how much money do you need
at the expense of like [ __ ] human
welfare not just american human welfare
worldwide like that [ __ ] wasn't
like a like a you know a
epidemic
and it affected a lot of people like
it's not like oh it happened elsewhere
like i know people that [ __ ]
happen to got swept up in this anyway
dopesick is
absolutely wonderful but if you're like
a recovering addict and stuff careful
because there's a lot of
terminology and process talk that may
like trigger you gotcha
anyway
um
let me tell you something kids right now
we're gonna do some q a
and if the question is kev when are you
coming out on the road to see me the
answer is
tomorrow i'll be in austin
if that's where you are
yeah and if you're not there then i'll
be in jersey and if you're not there
i'll be in rhode island if not there
jersey if not there
st louis chicago toronto vancouver clerk
is coming at you come see the story of
my life
um banff man
bamf hey
it's time for you to
choose
who gets to live and who gets to die no
you get to pick the questions as per
usual we put uh
the really heavy lifting
in jc's hands i was at a signing uh at
stash recently and
and uh was it the stash yes someone gave
me this [ __ ] amazing lighter oh [ __ ]
is that 3d yes it's like decoupage man
it's like a it's a lighter case
gorgeous yeah like a bob relief well
done that's awesome um man it was
[ __ ]
people are talented i want to try to
find this cat and be like make a bunch
we'll sell them at the store but it
looks like it takes time like you know
very
very very detailed yeah or he's just
three print 3d printing them just like
i saw jc on your instagram
you've been doing a lot of
like 3d printing wood blazing what are
you doing over there i uh
so i love thundercats and
uh i read a story along was read a story
a long time ago that
you know the sheath of excalibur was
actually better than excalibur because
you can't get wounded in battle if you
have the scabbard on
and similarly with thundercats i always
loved the claw shield more than the
actual sword of omens as a as a
weapon or device and so i found some guy
who had 3d modeled the claw shield from
thundercats that i've wanted
since i was four years old
uh and so i bought it and i 3d printed
it as like one giant
piece
so like i've scratched that
itch that i've had for 36 years to do
that how long did it take 36 years to 3d
print the shield how long did it take
uh 56 hours
jesus
jesus
like
nothing could go wrong at the 25 hour
mark yeah it's an and it's probably
about
i don't know 60 bucks worth of material
so if it does go wrong you you don't
want to
you don't want that to happen because
it's expensive
i mean sting could have been having sex
and come and you still would have been
making a [ __ ] claw shield
and i don't know if you know this or not
but he lasts a long time yeah not quite
claw shield length but still
thinking from somebody who knows he
lasts a long time
it's like this the whole time and i was
like i can't man i i i look back over my
shoulders don't make me call the police
i said hey that stings
thank you
i knew i'd find something that worked
i'm sending out an sos
stop
sure put a message in my bottle
um stand so close to you
[Laughter]
synchronously no i've got it
um all right
uh jc
uh before uh father of jocelyn
before you what well before we do q a
i've got some i've got some
comments from chat that i logged that i
thought were interesting
both uh shout out to james smith and
ellis delgado are going to see you
tomorrow in texas
uh there kids i'm going to show you
clerk story of my life i don't know why
i'm doing finger guns
edward
edward m said that you should turn the
car ride with your mom
into a podcast
like bring a little
tape recorder and just chop it up
um i just put a [ __ ] camera right on
the on the yeah like gopro
dash cam man do a little [ __ ] zoom
camera and
just shoot a couple gopros just do the
two shot over here and the single over
there
my uh
one of my favorite comments of the night
was from parade four four four four
he said they said oh my god i never miss
and it's usually later so i'm out of
sorts it's early but i guess my 90 year
old grandmother will be watching fat man
beyond with me tonight
oh that [ __ ] rocks
you know so 90 year old grandma got to
watch the bluetooth ad maybe you know
gives her some ideas
um
and she's like oh i've i've seen tears
in rain like you know she was able to
give a a monologue about a life well
lived and now only now
you know in the in the prime of her life
do they introduce
the chewable dick pill
i have seen the glory of the coming of
the lord
ah taylor
the sarah harley said oh my god mark has
a line in this movie when we played the
clerk's trailer or the clerk trailer
that's very fun
ah
that is very funny
and uh gregory robin said marvel is like
pizza and sex even the worst of marvel
movies are still kind of good with
regards to eternals and thor too
my point exactly we don't know what the
eternals is uh gonna be we haven't seen
it yet but let me tell you something
i agree with that sentiment 100 man
[ __ ] ain't no such thing as bad
marvel and and then uh
my comment for the night was uh nobody
except me says uh jc is looking like
he's about to perform at van's warp tour
2004 with my haircut
that's a red haircut isn't it it is a
red haircut oh you came over today to
pick up a cut of the movie jc of being
the assistant editor on clerks 3.
and like one of the first things i know
i was like my god your hair looks good
he's like red did it
um yeah that's a good cut man
look you look like a sports broadcaster
it's so not on brand but the baby's
birthday is this weekend so like i had
to i'm gonna have a photo forever one
year she's going to be one year old
she was a she was a stay puft
marshmallow baby for a moment
yeah adorbs
um
so okay don't forget don't forget kids
november 23rd
masters of the universe
revelation
part two
dropping like it's hot as they used to
say back in the day
uh
i would love to show you the trailer but
i'm afraid we'd get thrown off youtube
or something you could see the trailer
it's out there but
can't wait
it's so close
[Music]
um
so we had uh we had a really good chat
tonight a lot of good comments a lot of
really good questions
uh i picked these three so
anybody who i didn't pick you had good
questions just these were the ones i
picked
uh don't don't feel judged by
questions not [ __ ] picked i will say
just and it's not just because the
people who are watching this or the
people who submitted questions i feel
like we had
more
higher quality questions this show like
by a factor of like 50 than normal oh
say again what happened like we had
you know if we had a hundred questions
submitted tonight like 80 percent of
them were really good questions oh
typically it's it's not that you know
usually i'm like well
there are like five really good ones and
i'm gonna take these three i have a
whole bunch
you don't have to raise lower somebody
to raise somebody up you're like usually
these questions are dog [ __ ]
and i have to [ __ ] sift through them
to find even one presentable but tonight
everybody showed up everybody in chat
was really good
uh i was following along on chat which i
know as
some people call me out on a time of
time like don't look at chat look at me
but uh chat was [ __ ] fun and and uh
very
full of good information and stuff and
also they ran with some of our jokes for
like a long time which he's always
witness me
i like when the audience is funnier than
us and that's not hard to do we keep the
bar very low here we make it so that you
can watch this show and feel superior to
us in every way possible it's the
sketchbook version of the show like
you're drawing your own stuff yeah
you're comfortable around us because you
know that you're better than us
uh what do we got
okay uh michael monson
said question for the boys if you could
take any character ever and have them be
president
who would you choose and who would be
their vp
simon bob
i was just showing off my book
now available on amazon uh one more time
with that question i was so busy
thinking about selling something that i
forgot what you asked bamf
um
in uh
any character ever
to be the real life president and the
real life vice president
okay
jesus
one of my favorite characters
good dude
um i know there are a lot of people like
jesus but all those christians he can't
help it that a bunch of people took his
words and twisted them around and
you know most of the people that espouse
his name now don't really act like he
wanted them to act so
i'm a i'm not jesus is a good guy jesus
just jesus is just all right with me
also he'd be our first jewish president
so sure
hey i didn't say president he's vice oh
he's vice okay he's your backup guy man
he's the you know the heir and the spare
he's the one in the chamber mark like
gotcha fair enough uh jesus as vice
president
because you could trust him too he mean
it's not like jesus would ever be like
i'm gonna kill the president so that i
become president jesus is like i know
what it's like to be [ __ ] betrayed
and killed like trust me
do the job you're good
um
so jesus is my vice
richards
you know
tony i love tony stark but like you you
want somebody a little more serious as
your president
uh reed richards man most brilliant man
the marvel universe
and [ __ ] he could stretch
you know like any good president he's
got to learn to stretch and we know reed
richards could do that he could solve
some [ __ ] problems
there's a guy that built the fantastic
car
and herbie the robot if you used to
watch the tv show version
he could be president i'd [ __ ] make him
president for life make him like [ __ ]
caesar man just give him full authority
and [ __ ]
plus he ain't afraid to wear his age in
his temples you know right here you know
the polls go up by four points if he if
he leaves the gray oh yeah and and he
does it he don't do it for the polls
mark he's just he's like this is my
brand i've always been this guy
since i was a kid not the miles teller
version but you know every other
incarnation i'm smart see yeah
i could do things i'm smart
that's right richard's
afraid of the president but president
reeve richards ladies and gentlemen uh
like that was weird he's very insecure
about vice president jesus christ
uh those are my two mark
uh i'm i i'm going to choose not to
choose any fictional presidents because
it feels like cheating yeah i agree um
because you would want to choose [ __ ]
martin sheen yes like president bartlett
in a heartbeat and or
um president morgan freeman from deep
impact um you know guys who deal with
crisis very well
um but i am instead i i'm stead i am
instead going to choose
president
snake pliskin
um and vice president the duke of new
york a number
one wow i feel like it's a bit of a team
of rivals
did you just [ __ ] watch escape from
new york this time
i did not but
you know he clearly snake
knows what's best for america he's
willing to make the hard decisions
he's uh he's a veteran you know so he'd
do very well in the south
um the conservatives would love him the
democrats would love him because he's
also a bit of an anarchist
um he's got the one eye which makes him
[ __ ] badass and the duke of new york
has administrative experience that's a
dude that ran a city
you know he understands how to keep
order he understands how to make the
trains run
um i think it's a winning team i think
pliskin duke
2024
has a shot
um
so yeah and and now somebody make me
that t-shirt and i would uh i would wear
it
this is a random poll but dr fate
wouldn't be a bad [ __ ] president
either hmm that's true
that's true always seem fair and also
it's like you know you're being
you have the helmet of
naboo is that what it is the helmet of
or am i thinking of the bed take us to
the isle of naboombu
um the uh how the the yes it's the the
helmet of naboo i believe
um you know
kent nelson i'm not saying kevin nelson
i'm saying dr fate of course yeah no
that that checks out but you could do a
duel you could do kent and enza nelson
because they were both dr fate at one
point
there you got your two you got your surf
and turf president vice president and
they're all under one helmet and [ __ ] so
you're saving money
which is important in government from
what i understand yeah clearly yeah
you've got a balance of budget it's all
about resource management
uh
similarly i feel like mufasa would be a
pretty decent president mufasa yeah very
you know and practical too like here's a
guy who's not afraid to like look we eat
the [ __ ] zebras like
we got it like that's the circle of life
the circle of life ain't just that
little hole under your mom's tail simba
the circle alive
the circle of life is we eat the [ __ ]
zebras it's that simple the pink eye of
life don't get [ __ ] friendly with the
zebras because you will [ __ ] eat one
before the day is out yeah so like dear
america
i have your best interest at heart
because i want you all to be healthy
because i'm going to be eating like four
percent of you
so
it's just all about good health care
good schools you know there's an
exercise program you know we want this
to be the healthiest populist the world
has ever seen because healthy is
delicious
he's got and he's got a great commanding
voice you'd listen everything that
president said oh [ __ ] yeah we're
raising texas are you yes okay you go
ahead why did you do that sooner
i find your life the [ __ ] out of us
we love your voice do it
um what a great question if only we were
in the bar we can give him something
cool but here we just give him one of
these
and a jeff's kiss
i i haven't seen season two but i think
after season one i would pick ted lasso
as president and coach as vp
because i i feel like you know they can
do anything
i'm half with you i would definitely go
ted lasso as president but i would
probably go
um
um
uh roy kent for vice
i get to see that bring the hammer down
you need a ted ted is great and [ __ ]
i love a humanist but
we are talking about politics government
you need a show of strength and [ __ ]
roy camping like oy [ __ ] off is
he's a [ __ ] wanker he's always been a
wager
is he being a pity little [ __ ] is he
rick golds hey putin
[ __ ] we got he was doing press
recently we got to get him on this
[ __ ] show man you did his podcast you
got the winner no i loved his podcast it
was so fun before i knew he was [ __ ]
uh gonna be one of my favorite actors of
all time
that character is so [ __ ] fantastic
and he is like absolutely adorable two
of them and keely together
i was so sad to see uh the end of uh ted
lasso season two and i was like well
it'll be back soon and somebody pointed
out it won't be back for a [ __ ] year
and i was like no
they get stuck ow
now
and then i got over it you know i was
like you got [ __ ] to do i remember how
television works so it's okay yes
oh it's like [ __ ] stops you know another
show will come along you'll be fine
um boy that show's good all right what
do we got next jc all right uh susvera
uh wants to know
what
native smells would each of the og
avengers use
what native sense you mean for native
deo sense yeah
i'll tell you right now
got this sugar cookie body wash like
is
i'm gonna leave it on my desk and just
inhale it from time to time it is pure
happiness uh in a little bottle and [ __ ]
so this
who's this smell like
captain america should smell like sugar
cookies no
yeah i guess
what what you have to think about it
that long for [ __ ] what's more
american than a goddamn sugar cookie i
don't know uh [ __ ] pine forest or
some [ __ ]
oh nobody wants to smell like a pie for
us everyone wants to smell like sugar
cookies could you imagine even if you
were getting punched in the [ __ ] face
because you're a super villain you're
getting punched in a [ __ ] face by a
sugar cookie hand there's something
pleasant about it
all right i'm looking up i'm on native
deu
natives website so i can see all of the
scents they have
i'm just gonna i'm gonna put it in my
mustache so all i smell are sugar
you like that scene in in um sons of the
lambs when scott glenn tosses [ __ ]
jodie foster
the little things you don't smell the
dead bodies i want to smell like sugar
cookies because i'm about to enter a
room of death
clarice
um
all right wait so where were we what
what sense would the avengers smell like
i say captain america smells like sugar
cookie i don't say
black widow smells like uh
i mean i don't know if they do this
scent but what's that [ __ ] patchouli
really
yeah she seems like a patchouli gal to
me she seems crunchy she'd be on tour
with the dead if if she had the chance i
think so um and also rugged like you
know and russian that helps as well
i mean does does native mega vodka scent
because that would be
i would imagine what the black widow
would be into um
tony stark
i'm gonna go with uh
let me go with the strawberry essence i
don't even know if native does that do
you have a list of what native does
i'm i'm pulling them up
let's see we got coconut and vanilla
cucumber and mint
lavender and rose coconut vanilla
that's hawkeye
although i like coconut that's tony
stark
remember at one point he was like i
taste coconut did he say that when he
was like
it tastes like metal
coconut was getting powered up and [ __ ]
i think it was iron man 2.
um
what other flavors
um
hold on a sec i'm trying to i wish they
just had a list but they don't quite
um
pergamon pine
um surf and cmos
sandalwood and fig
um
sandalwood is thor
and fig that sounds like a [ __ ]
asgardian thing bring me the figs
another that checks out
uh
cucumber and mint feels like it's a hulk
thing
very good call
um lavender and rose could be black
widow
good point there is no patchouli so yes
lavender and rose we'll save that for
the black widow
um unscented would be hawkeye billy
dilly unscented yeah
although that [ __ ] the new trailer
like all the trailers for that series
looks
charming as [ __ ] i think uh that's how
they redeem hawkeye they're gonna make
you love hawkeye this
you're going to love hawkeye they're
going to ted lasso this [ __ ] by the
end of it you're going to be like i love
this guy
i i i do tend to be smartly hawkeye but
i did see a picture i want to say it was
like on harold pereneus pereno's
instagram of him stopping by jeremy
renner's house with his kids for
trick-or-treating and renner had dressed
up as hawkeye and was handing out candy
i was like you know what
okay yeah all right you know not bad
not on par with ibushemi dressing up as
oh hey young fellow young people
me been delivering candy this year did
you guys see
it was a meme
and it was uh
paul rudd out with his daughter i
believe
maybe a niece or something and she was
dressed as the wasp
and rather than go as ant-man he went
his [ __ ] weird l
like he could have been ant-man and the
wasp for this little girl and he's like
no i'm gonna roll with weird l tonight
that's the sequel we've all been waiting
for weird hell on the wasp
that's a dude was like you know what i
haven't had the marvel trainer in a
while so like i don't know if i could
squeeze into this costume but weird out
it's just a funny suit so sure
i love rocky road
that's my
go-to weirdo
yoda
the least recognizable um all right that
was fun we gave it up we got close
enough to get a jeff's kiss to that and
i'll tell you really jeff's kissed the
[ __ ] out of that
was probably the good folk said
native
it
god damn it i had no idea until tonight
how much i love the smell of sugar
cookies
this shit's sulfate free paraben free
dye free
falate free it's got no latte in it
well all right [ __ ] god damn it
you're [ __ ] hard
becomes an addict
hoppering you're just [ __ ]
[Music]
um all right third question of the night
bamf
uh okay last one uh this is from uh oh
god screw this uh if you could have a
dead or retired filmmaker take on a
marvel or dc film
who would it be and what project
and the
example was like orson welles would do a
magneto biopic
oh
strong pull all right um okay
okay
let me let me think here
george roy hill
directed a bunch of movies that i love
including
and not
limited to
the sting
butch cassidy and the sundance kid
a the buddy movie from which every
[ __ ] buddy movie draws
whether they know it or not um
and the world according to garp
three of my all-time favorite movies
so he's not an obvious choice but those
are great movies if you've never seen
them
so i'm gonna pick george rory hill
now
the sting
is a [ __ ] caper
yep
butch cassian sundance kid is a buddy
movie about
two old gunslingers [ __ ]
[Music]
trying to eke it out in the modern world
and
you can't swim the fall will kill you
bolivia
um and then
uh the world according to garp is uh a
beautiful adaptation of the john irving
uh novel
that covers the span of uh of a life
one of my favorite books ever written if
not my favorite book
um and the movie adaptation was equally
wonderful
so
that guy those movies those particular
credits what does that say to me that he
should handle
okay
part of me wants to say heroes for hire
because the guy who did butch casting
the sundance kid could really do
power man and iron fist
however we've seen that so i'm trying to
think of something we haven't seen
um
george roy hill but direct and what
wow it's dead air and i'm losing the
audience because like george roy hill
who the [ __ ]
um
i'm gonna go with
um
george roy hill
does excalibur
okay
did not see that coming but sure
i was singing i'm trying to think about
like they've done a number of x-men
movies of course but the mcu hasn't done
their x-men movie yet and i'm thinking
about what incarnation in the hands of
george roy hill you know i was
initially i wanted to say god loves man
kills because i couldn't wait to see
that but he's totally wrong for god
loves man kills but he would be
excellent for an adaptation of excalibur
you know [ __ ] uh kitty pride and and
lockheed or dragon
and [ __ ] all the [ __ ] british
x-men kids
that'd be and granted he's known for
doing british movies but i think that
level of mirth and warmth and life ended
you know adventure intrigue i think he
could handle that pretty well not the
sexiest answer in the world but
let me stand by it if for no other
reason than to reiterate three movies
that you probably never thought about or
heard of or haven't watched in a long
time and are worth your time
the sting
wonderful [ __ ] movie
butch cassian sundance kid a fantastic
[ __ ] american film one of the best
and the world according to garp robin
williams
in an amazing performance
glenn close in an amazing performance
john lithgow
in an amazing performance like
give these movies your time over to you
mark
okay i have uh two suggestions
uh i had some time to think
sydney lumet
doing daredevil
oh
that's good
that's good
new york filmmaker
specialized in crime and then the the
urban
day afternoon for god's sakes
um
and
uh
the the
frank miller john byrne
wolverine limited series the the
wolverine goes to japan
um by akira kurosawa
oh my god
wow [ __ ] your [ __ ] blows my [ __ ] out
of water that was great
yeah [ __ ] that's pretty mental right
there
um
kubrick
kubrick
could do
um
i would like to see kubrick do hellstrom
son of satan ooh okay man made the
shining one of the spookiest [ __ ]
movies ever made let's see what he could
do with the son of satan
that'd be fun bam
this is a fun game who else is dead my
career so let's do kevin smith's career
i would do uh penny marshall
and put her
behind fantastic four
and do it period and do it earnest
like do it just
saccharin what's the period 60s 60s
wow with penny marshall
you you got me on i'm petty marshall and
fantastic four yeah why not
but i'm i'm thinking i'm trying to think
if there's something she'd be even
better suited for what a great poll
penny marshall man [ __ ]
you want to talk about a run big
an amazing movie awakenings an amazing
movie
[ __ ] a league of their own an amazing
movie she hit like a [ __ ] trifecta
like
incredible career
wow what a great pull yeah i was trying
to think of something
i feel like new mutants isn't quite
right
um but maybe could be but jonathan demi
oh
demi
i mean which demi we talked we talking
married to the mob demi or we talking
silence and a lamb's demi
oh song is oh you know who would be
better for new mutants though
john hughes
oh
you're gonna make me cry
oh my god a john hughes teenage [ __ ]
mutant movie yeah
or you can just do straight up x-men
with john hughes just make it [ __ ] oh
my god poor [ __ ] cyclops is so sad
because you pulled the elephant trunk
it's supposed to turn on but it didn't
wolverine taping butts together and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow man wow i can't believe i i can't
believe george roy hill
that i went with that's the currency i
spent on this show one [ __ ]
you guys george roy hill
i saw someone in chat said and i thought
this was very poignant john singleton
doing luke cage hmm
that would mean he wanted to he wanted
to do that he also wanted to do black
panther for years yeah
um i was trying to think of it david
moses mostio says tony scott in the
suicide squad and i was like that's a
pretty good answer tony scott had that
slick ass style man
uh kabuki kids said david cronenberg
doing hellblazer but number one david
cronenberg's still alive yeah still
working yeah yeah
so there's still a chance that's a good
idea
outside the rules of art although dario
argento doing hellblazer would be
something
oh but wait he's still alive too i don't
think he is i thought dario passed
let's see no i think he's alive because
they did that superior remake
and i think he commented on it i think
he's still alive
um
yeah
pure true metal says penny marshall
doing wonder woman 1960.
uh russell cook says robert altman's
justice league
holy [ __ ] john ashford says john ford
doing rawhide kid what a great poll that
is oh that's great i mean john ford
doing jonah hex would also be awesome
bicky's restoration said sam peckinpah
deadshot
um john neuromorph says john landis
doing black panther but in the style of
coming to america that's never going to
happen in this lifetime right and also
still alive yes good point
good point he's not dead
um yes everyone's chats saying dario is
definitely still alive he is my bad i i
looked it up
um cronenberg's been doing a lot of
acting lately
uh
stanley dunn and doing x-men versus the
evil brotherhood movie
okay
irving kirsten looking adam strange says
braden goss i'll take that
that was good
maria ochoa said the stanley diamond
thing that was very funny
um i could do this all night just oh
this is a good idea but again this
dude's alive john woo doing the punisher
yes but these
filmmaker has to be dead
man all right mandel harvey said leonard
nimoy but didn't give a suggestion but
there's a great
a great uh
name that could direct and clearly
directed like one of the greatest star
trek movies but also directed three men
and a baby
very versatile filmmaker very versatile
there's a cat that could do silver
surfer
um
yeah i was gonna say robert wise for
like star jammers
isaac cushman said milo foreman
spider-man
i i would like to see oh george
junis missile pointed out george romero
okay
marvel zombies clearly will be handled
by george romero ladies and gentlemen
and
no one will be admitted in after the
[ __ ] show begins
um all right let's move on from that
[ __ ] that was good that was fun
um that was all three that's all three
jesus
we started the show at like well about 5
30 or something like that and give or
take
now 806 i think we've run out of show
kids
uh mark what do you got to sell them
while i [ __ ] take another hit off
this
sugar cookie native body wash
uh i i do not have much to sell i
although i do remember seeing in chat
uh earlier out
the spider-man one shot that i wrote the
uh amazing shutter bug
is part of uh i think it just came out
as a hero's reborn collection a trade
paperback so if if one wants to find it
your local comic book shop um be my
guest
um that local comic book shop could very
well be jay and zombob secret stash in
red bank new jersey there it is
um what about your uh uh
uh let [ __ ] know shirt
uh yes one could buy the humble shirts
or the resistances fertile shirts
at uh
at embattled clothing
did you catch my
[Laughter]
yes
yes america
my little nod to uh
to what was her name mary catherine mary
catherine gallagher
uh yes in battleclothing.com you can get
be humble or uh or uh resistances
fertile
there may or may not be no more shirts
coming from that line where we're
thinking and working as we speak
speaking of shirts coming from a line
geeky jerseys
uh provided they made these jerseys
these quick stop uh jerseys for for
clerks 3.
so we're doing jerseys with them and uh
they're going to be selling that there's
this gorgeous movies jersey they're
going to be releasing and then also
uh they're doing uh leonardo reapers
which uh randall wore on his hat and
clerks too and they're going to be doing
uh the monroeville zombies jersey that
seth rogen wore in zach and mary make a
porno and spoilers jason muse wears in
uh clerks three
so um
look for those soon i don't know when
they go on sale they're doing them one
at a time and stuff and they're only
making a certain amount and stuff like
370 to keep with the 37 theme but that's
gonna be [ __ ] cool i've seen them and
i've worn them and they're [ __ ] dope
uh meantime if you're like oh i can't
get enough [ __ ] kevin smith and you
live in austin or you live in st louis
or you live in chicago or you live in uh
um toronto or vancouver come see me
and my documentary clerk not my
documentary i didn't make it malcolm
ingram he directed it and he's going to
be there with me we're going to do q a
after the show and stuff so come on out
watch two hour movie about
me and my fat ass and my goofy
shenanigans over the last few years and
whatnot and uh we'll chitchat afterwards
it'll be a
good old [ __ ] time i was gonna say
gay old time but i want to get sued by
hannah barbera um and if you're not if
you're like i don't want to see a
[ __ ] movie about you but i am in
rhode island and i do like comic books
well then on friday come to the rhode
island comic con kids that's where i'm
going to be with all the kids from
clerks man jay
dante [ __ ] randall
if i get
veronica elias it's gonna be crazy
um that's where i'm gonna be and stuff
so next week i'm on the road do i have a
show on tuesday night yes i have a show
in
toronto so we won't be doing this
tuesday but we can do it wednesday night
are you guys free on wednesday
um potentially um i would have to check
my schedule
and see what's what um and but we also
have and we were going to slot it into
the feed was the show that i taped with
ming chen
at the northern fan con
um so what people have been asking for
when they get to see it
and
this may or may not be the perfect time
for said uh development
um i
looked and chat here and realized that
uh
robert russell
said richard donner
guardians of the galaxy richard donner
anything superman three
um yeah man [ __ ] absolutely with you
on that one [ __ ] richard donner good
pull
now but now i'm just sad thinking about
all the [ __ ] cool directors who are
dead people whose work like you know
meant the world to me and
chased me into a field you know like
they made
storytelling seem [ __ ] fun
but as much as i love richard donner let
me tell you something he never made
[ __ ] sugar cookie bath washer
good folks at native my god this is
making me so happy it's in my mouth but
i don't even care
just chew it
something
my whole life in my mouth but i don't
even care
let me tell you kids a bit about dick
dino he did a lot of things a lot of
things well you know what he never did
he never made sugar cookie body wash and
then he made a hell of a superman
picture but he never made no sugar
cookie body wash only native does that
we thank our sponsors the good folks at
native go to nativedeo.com
fat man and i'm sure they'll give you a
prize or some such [ __ ]
discount off your order
or
the good folks at blue chew is it
bluechew.com it is indeed luchu.com
fat man and i'm sure
they'll reward you heavily as well man
but we can keep the cards
for sponsoring our
silly little show here we thank jc
taking time away from this near
one-year-old kid
to [ __ ] make sure that this show gets
into your [ __ ] house even though
we're not at the cantina um so as he
said earlier don't forget canteen is on
[ __ ] fire people like pandemic what
[ __ ] covet who
they're out there drinking partying
talking about [ __ ] star wars and [ __ ]
go to the cantina when again man it's
coming villainy cantina right there in
hollywood on hollywood boulevard
hollywood hollywood boulevard
we got uh
in a couple weeks november
13th i believe which is a saturday we're
going to open early
we're doing all ghostbusters all day all
night so it's
ghostbusters themed cocktails we've got
the la ghostbusters there for photo ops
we've got props we're gonna have a life
size blow up ecto-1 driving off the roof
of the bar
um
when is uh when is afterlife come out
the 19th i believe yeah the next
week at midnight wednesday or thursday
or however that works this week is the
eternals
happens on friday
so are they the next week or the week
after the next week they're the week
after the next week so there's a space
between yeah the 12th the weekend of the
12th and then the 19th is ghostbusters
the space between space between
the eternals and afterlife
when it starts singing dave it's time to
go kids
and when i start singing dave badly
that's when it's really time to go he's
slapping the space
stuck in the space man dave matthews
i'm not
no that's all good i'm just kevin smith
but you know what this show don't happen
without the other guy
give it up for master mark bernardin the
maestro himself
thumbs up he just gave you i did up the
bridge of a [ __ ] starship
now we roll on this show
um there it is kids we unpacked all the
[ __ ] news the nerdy news the geeky
news and
now it's time for us to go hopefully
i'll see some of you in
on the road over the course of the next
week and then hopefully we all get to
reconvene on
wednesday and perhaps by then both mark
and i will have seen
eternals and have something to say about
it indeed
uh but until that time
here come those words that nobody wants
to hear that's
fat man beyond for this week man
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernardin
tune in next time same
fat time same
fat channels podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith we're [ __ ]
meta whatever that is
jeff's kiss everybody